I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursu into executive
order
2020-4 this is a public body authorized
to meet electronically this is a public
hearing with potential for executive
sessions to be held throughout please
note that there is no fiscal location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this Comm
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and the select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice of this
meeting complies with house rules in RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
27136 or email
HCS
l.st do.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assist us
Brad geman who is the committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by a roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting required on the
right to
know Vice chairman Wells here
representative F here and I'm with
representative
Hopper representative Hopper I think I'm
here representative green I'm here
representative Wallace present
representative testerman here
representative true pres in the
committee room representative prep here
representative
du the clerk is present representative
har G presid representative
TZ she's going to be late
representative o' pres
alone representative
B president alone representative news
here and alone in my office
representative
Newman pres and and my wife is in the
house
representative I'm present I'm at home
um there's family and pets
representative Conley pres
representative F
Knight
present representative Bradley present
and I'm here with my
daughters chairman the chair is present
Mr chairman we're waiting for
representative and representative office
when when the members U do join us we
will just know for the record that they
are now
inance at this time representative uh
pres green is going to lead us in the
pledge of
leers IED Al to the of the United States
of America and to the for it stands one
nation God indivisible withy and jusice
for
all
than
this time we'll open the public hearing
on outville
morning members of the Justice Public
Safety Committee I'll keep my testimony
very brief
uh I'm introducing this bill this bill
that we passing last year
believe
and calendar however by the time it made
his way to the Senate due to the 19
pandemic this bill was uh Ted in the
Senate not act upon so it was been
refiled I in the interest of the
committee I will yield my time to Mad
speaker Don who is in attendance today
who would be able to explain the film
a lot better than I can and just a
history lesson this committee was
actually estblished
in the
first by
that so I find it
that
can you hear me now yeah yes it helps if
I
unmute good morning uh for the record my
name is Donna scitec I am a 10-year
member of the parole board uh and I am
uh offering uh this bill on their behalf
uh we requested this bill last year in
response to observations from the
performance audit that was conducted and
to update some sections of our chapter
to improve efficiency and assure Public
Safety and reflect our actual
practice uh as has been said uh this
committee passed this bill
unanimously uh last session but it was a
uh casualty of the uh shutdown because
of covid so here it is again so for the
benefit of those who didn't hear it last
year uh I had provided my testimony I
had emailed it to all the members I
don't know whether you have it or not
but anyway um I I'll walk you through
the bill if you have it in front of you
um sections one and two are truly
housekeeping uh Provisions uh because
we're repealing
um RSA 651a which has to do with uh
hearings at nine
months we need
to uh repeal it in the in the C in the
as a cross reference in the involuntary
commitment so that's just a housekeeping
thing sections one and two of the bill
on section three unless you have the
whole chapter in front of you you can't
figure out what's going on in the
definition sections of the uh chapter it
defines nonviolent crimes as all the
crimes except
for the ones in
65153 which are eight crimes and in my
handout I've I've listed them it's you
know first-degree murder uh robbery
aggravated for sexual assault kidnapping
arson eight
crimes and it said
and and the the definition of nonviolent
crimes also
lists eight other crimes having to do
with violation of protective order
second degree assault Reckless conduct
stalking tampering with W fonus use of
firearm eight separate
crimes so since the there is no
reference to nonviolent crimes in the
chapter anymore that's a a remnant of uh
house bill um excuse me Senate Bill 500
from uh 2010 that has been modified so
many times so rather than Define
nonviolent crimes which is a phrase not
used in the chapter we're going to
define the violent crimes the eight that
are listed in
651 A5 and also the eight that are
currently listed uh in the chapter
and the reference to violent crimes is
is important because it's used in
determining the length of any uh parole
revocation okay uh section four
uh of the bill uh which is on page two
on the top um is a recommendation from
the uh LBA audit they the current law
requires a 15 to 30-day notice
requirement to the county attorney to
the police chief and to the victim and
to the public before the
hearing the audit observed that the
statute didn't distinguish between
release hearings revocation hearings
reconsideration hearings and review
hearings those are the four kinds of
hearings we
have the other than the release hearings
revocations reconsideration and
reviews can only result in either
extending the period of incarceration
for somebody who's already been approved
at a duly noticed hearing we don't think
there's any need to notify the uh police
chief the County Attorney every time we
see this person who's been approved for
parole again uh the right to no law
still applies uh so we do Post notice of
all kinds of hearings on our website
this just clarifies that the 15 to
30-day notice to the police the County
Attorney the public and the victim
applies only to release
hearings uh section five uh make several
changes in the uh that affect the length
of committ for parole violation so
somebody's on parole they commit a
parole violation they come back back to
us for a revocation hearing at that
hearing uh if they are found true to
have violated
the uh the
board is Guided by this section of of
the law with regard to what kind of a
sanction we can impose the general
sanction for any violation of parole is
days
however that we can give more or less if
it meets certain other criteria but in
the instance of the standard 90day
setback the statute would require that
we release them after 90 days even if
they hadn't completed their programs
even if they didn't have a place to go
even if they didn't have treatment set
up in the community we would like to
change the law to specify that violators
who get the 90-day sanction meet the
criteria for parole before they're being
released just like everybody else who is
released people who have a 90day setback
should meet the criteria for parole and
I've listed the criteria parole on the
on the back of the handout that I
provided uh we have had inmates I mean
they all know they call it a 90-day
Mando I'm out of here I don't have to
tell you where I'm
going how it's hard to supervise
somebody if you don't know where they're
going so we we need this we need them to
meet the criteria for
parole uh this the second change uh is
to modify the reference to uh the
dynamic risk factors for sex offenders
who violate their parole it's a
practical matter if you're a sex
offender we don't care whether you
violated your Dynamic risk factors we
care that you're a sex offender and you
violated parole so you should be
eligible for an more than 90 days in in
certain cases so um
we're eliminating the reference to the
dynamic risk
factors uh the uh next section uh also
it's it's on uh page two line 26 and
also on page three line 14 this corrects
a
mistake in the list of violent crimes
you saw in the the current list of
non-violent crimes it says all crimes
except for these two categories eight
that are listed in one section and eight
that are listed in the statute well they
forgot to carry it over to the section
on the the length of time we're allowed
to uh recommit somebody the length of
the setback this is when the definition
of violent crime comes comes into play
so we want to be make clear that if you
violate any of the 16 crimes that we've
listed you are eligible for either an
enhanced
sentence
excuse me I'm
sorry you're eligible for an enhanced
sentence or you're inh
eligible to have a reduced
sentence uh so that this corrects a
mistake uh also uh on page two line 34
we're we're eliminating references to
the focused evidence-based programming
aimed at re-engaging parole Le in their
parole plan
as envisioned in Senate Bill 500 there
would be uh
a 90 days set back for everybody
regardless of whether it was your first
or second or what your crime was there
was supposed to have a special program
in a separate place to engage paroles in
in their re-engage them in their parole
plan this never happened both for
budgetary reasons and also because
everybody doesn't need the same program
uh right now they they design programs
about the the needs of uh each of the
inmates so this bill repeals the
reference to that specific program which
never
existed uh section section six removes
the requirement that the Parole Board
review every Parolees file every three
years uh that's never been done uh by
the parole board in its 30s something
years of existence uh because it's
already being done by the chief of the
each of the district offices so it's a a
burden for the parole board if we were
to do it and it's already being done so
nobody gets lost in the
system uh section seven uh of the bill
contains two
repeals right now we
have a provision on the law that says
applications for parole can be heard in
in non-public session but our rules have
long allowed anyone to get an audio
recording of parole hearings so when I
came on as chairman I said this is crazy
if you can get an audio hearing why
can't you be there so I opened up the
parole hearings uh to the public um so
we have been conducting them in public
the LBA pointed out this discrepancy so
this bill cures that by doing away with
the section of the right to know law
that says that parole hearings will be
heard in non-public session uh parole
records however will continue to be
non-public
and the last provision of the bill on
page three line 29 eliminates the
requirement to hold a parole hearing for
an inmate nine months before as Max
under Senate Bill 500 as originally
envisioned everybody would be
automatically released if they were
still there nine months before their
maximum sentence regardless of their
behavior they would just be
released um that law was changed so that
they are entitled to a hearing nine
months before their Max okay so they
come into us they uh have a hearing but
they don't have a plan they don't have
they've have terrible disciplinary rate
there's no way they're going to be
released so this bill does away with the
requirement that we have the hearing you
should know that this doesn't take away
any rights from any prisoner anybody who
is
here uh as long
as nine months before the maximum at any
time time when they've got their um
housing plan when they've completed
their program when they've meet the
criteria for parole they can ask for a
hearing so this doesn't take away any of
their rights it just takes away uh the
requirement that we have a hearing for
somebody we know isn't isn't ready to be
released so the uh passage of this bill
will uh enhance our efficiency and
Effectiveness and I hope you will
support it as aop pass just as you did
last year I would be happy to answer any
questions you may
have
questions I guess I've said it
all than you much question
somebody's not
muted somebody is
now and thank you thank you for taking
my question can you tell me what uh a
dynamic risk factor
is uh the dynamic risk factors are those
that that uh can be changed um
homelessness loss of support substance
abuse non-compliance with treatment
thank
you any further questions from the
committee seeing thatone we thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
Mr chairman have a great
day
Mr chairman I see no one with their
hands
raised no I don't see anybody Mr
chairman I guess we will close the
public hearing on house bille 178
FN
and Mr chairman we had uh we we had two
people signing in in support of the bill
and five people signing in in
opposition
number we have have some
time sh out in the
hallway take your
time
fast open to
[Music]
suggestions
this time we're going to the executive
session of House Bill 178 relative to
the parole of prison and the procedures
of the adult board here recognizes
representative wel to make a motion make
a motion we find House Bill 178 FN not
to
pass has been seconded by
represent represent B wish to speak to
your motion
this is the same bill that we passed the
last
year
uh most of us have heard it
before the request it answers some of
the problems of outlin in the
audit I think
we good B that's
it thank you representative the chairman
now open the question up for
discussion seeing no seeing
representative Newman you recognize
thank you Mr chairman my my only concern
that was an excellent summary of The Bu
of the bill I mean of yeah the bill and
um my only concern is there are a lot of
laws that we're going to be considering
that have to do with parole and some of
the uh wording has been changing in
there that that relates to parole so we
probably have to refer back to that and
see how the two things might conflict
when we consider those other bills thank
you Mr
chairman thank you
represent seeing No Hands raised
uh the question be put forward the cler
Now call the rooll if you in favor of
the motion of about to pass please say
yay if you are opposed please say
no than chman W hi representative Burke
yes representative Hopper yes
representative green yes
representative sorry
guys and just a
reminder
is is the house computer
muted I would just remind the members in
the room that also make sure that your
speakers are also muted as long as well
as your
microphones representative testerman yes
yes representative true y representative
Pratt yes representative yes the clerk
votes yes representative Harry G yes
representative
pandelakis representative o'n yes
representative Bon yes representative
Muse yes representative Newman yes
representative Balden
yes representative connley yes
representative Klein Knight yes
representative Bradley yes chairman the
chair votes yesman the vote is 20 yay
zero Nay by a vote of 20 Ys and zero
Nays motion to pass has
pass majority
report all right
ask
[Music]
question this time we'll close the
executive session on I
[Music]
Jenifer was it 21 or 20 20
who
for
this time we were going to re reopen the
executive session on House Bill
238 and I believe at the time that when
we recessed there was a motion of legis
that was made represent T you recognize
uh yes uh I'd like to withdraw my
I
Al it's not required for that to be
seconded I second
that
second second the motion to
withdraw repres you be recognized for a
motion yes I'd like to uh house B 238 uh
we should retain
that
the motion
second M question now be open for
discussion you
recognized thank you Mr
chairman um it was clear on Monday that
I had no idea what this bill did are the
laws that really were effective um since
that time I've uh taken the time to
educate
myself uh by talking to
attorneys
and I see no reason to retain this bill
I think that we should uh rule it in
expedient to legislate this bill uh
would uh add an exception to the uh uh
provocations section of uh well it's not
a law but the Publications and I see no
reason to do that those those probations
are a high enough bar to uh clear
without making exceptions so if you want
to retain it I'll vote for it but I
really think that the motion should be
inex speeding into legislate thank
you representative BR
right thank you chairman um I think this
bill should be ought to pass I feel
especially I mean what we saw on Monday
it definitely shows that this bill is
needed um it was
unexcusable
and I don't know how we could retain
this bill so I'll be
[Music]
opposing representative Newman you
recognized thank you Mr chairman
um my feeling about this bill is I think
it's an important bill that it ought to
pass but I um don't see a great
likelihood of that so therefore I will
reluctantly vote to retain it so that we
can have the opportunity to work on this
bill sometime between in the remainder
of this session thank
you Muse you
recognized thank you I I also believe uh
that this should that we should be
voting uh ought to pass on this bill
um I think the folks who testified made
a an extremely compelling case uh on
Friday as to why this bill should pass
um I I also think that some of the the
issues um that people in the lgbtq
community face uh when it comes to
getting a fair Shake in the courts and
getting a fair Shake in the legislature
uh were Exposed on
Friday and uh I believe that this
legislation uh is necessary and I will
oppose the motion to retain
it you Mr chair I too propose the retain
I think that it should go for as AR to
pass um there were compelling
testimonies on our last visit group
session and um and just in new of what
what transpired that day it definitely
part to
pass representative Conley thank you Mr
chairman I agree this bill should be off
passed the bills that this committee has
retained have been complicated there
have been easily
identifiable issues that need to be
resolved through a subcommittee or or an
intense work session I don't see any of
those issues with this bill it seems
like we understand uh what this bill
intends to do I think we can recognize
the problem it intends to
address
and uh seeing no real um things that
needed to be fixed I would suggest off
pass and I'll vote no on
retaining representative
KN thank you chair um with all due
respect I think we're making a horrible
mistake here I think this needs to be
octop passed we have some of the highest
um lgbtq communities population in this
state and we couldn't even respect them
enough to give them their own hearing we
lumped it in with another bill and on
top of that we had a member of this
[Music]
body can you warn me before you just
you're not recognized to speak at this
time representative KN you're now
speaking out of
order and to the extent that anyone
found the scheduling of these house
bills disrespectful that point of order
is no longer proper and should have been
addressed on Monday during the public
years
the chairs May exercise his discretion
and not recognize anyone to speak a
second time and who anyone who hasn't
spoke already wishes to speak please
please raise your
hand seeing No Hands
raised put the
question Ro if you in favor of the
motion to please say yay if you oppose
you say
that Vice chairman Welch hi repres
representative Bert yes representative
Hopper yes representative green yes
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative TR
yay representative TR you said vot yes
yeah representative Pratt yes
representative du yes the clerk votes
yes representative Harriet GA
no representative
pantelakis Representative o'n
bordon
Bourne you need to turn on your camera
and you are also muted and it would be
easier if the members left their cameras
on while we're in voting mode sorry
chairman uh I vote
no representative muse
no representative Newman
no Representative bden
no representative Conley no
representative
Bradley
no chairman chair votes yes excuse me
chair I didn't get called to
vote the represented was not in in her
seat when come on I was right here you
could see me come
on you you're telling other members that
don't have their camera
on control yourself represent night
you've been
warned remember was not we can see the
seat the member's camera's on when the
matter question was called she not the
member was not in their seat therefore
they are not allowed to enter the
room so this that's the ruling of the
chair vote is 11 yay 8 Nay by a vote of
11 Ys 8 Nays the motion to
rain
passed we now close the executive
session on House Bill 2
238 and we will be in recess to to
9:45 Mr chairman I'd like to ask you a
question
that
GA
thee
this time we are opening uh the public
hearing on House Bill
598 and House Bill
138 Bill 598 is relative to the portion
of a minimum sentence to be
served to be eligible for in house 138
is allowing CH serving life sentence to
be El after 25
years this time the chair recognizes
representative do I have to
go the middle chair representative G is
recognized to introduce house
morning
um in the 1980s we saw a wave of
so-called yet tough on crime policies
these included mandatory minimums three
strikes laws and a policy known as truth
and sentencing which required that
people serve a certain percentage of
their minimum sentence before being
eligible for
parole these 1980 policies were stream
and we spent the past few decades
walking them back this committee passed
legis
legistation already this session to
remove some of the remaining mandatory
minimums that we still have on the books
here in New
Hampshire this requirement has prevented
New Hampshire from being able to Grant
time off for good behavior meaning for
decades we have lacked the ability to
incentivize
Rehabilitation essential purpose for
incarceration moreover truth and
sentencing has resulted in people
spending more time in prison meaning a
higher price tag for taxpayers who have
to pay for every day someone spends in
prison with one year in prison costing
taxpayers roughly
$40,000 truth and sentencing is
expensive extreme and outdated
many other the states have repealed or
amended their truth in sentencing laws
including those States that had less
extreme versions to begin
with and I say that because New
Hampshire was the only state during that
time that went for
100%
the 1980 notion that if we just extr we
just extreme enough in our punishments
we could deter or even End crime has
been consistently
disproven extreme sentencing causes far
more harm than good the goal of
incarceration should be
Rehabilitation and we need to amend our
policies
accordingly HB 598 would amend our truth
in sentencing law to require that people
serve 50% of their minimum before being
El eligible to apply for a parole being
eligible for parole does not mean that a
person will automatically be parole it
means they can apply and the parole
board will make a determination on a
Case by casee
basis Let Me Clear be clear this
legislation will not automatically
result in people let out of prison soon
it simply swaps a one-size fitall policy
for one that allows the parole board to
consider the unique circumstance of an
individual's case their rehabilitative
Journey during incarceration and whether
not to Grant
Parole in
2015 approximately 30 States had this
law
and we call it
TI the District of
Columbia have them in place in contrast
States like Indiana Texas Maryland and
Nebraska say inmates must serve at least
50% of their
time I allow my time to others that have
done more research and can speak more to
the
issue
see seeing No Hands raised want to thank
the representative for
testimony and I would just
clarify this rule right now generally
speaking when a representative who a
member of committee produces a bill
they're not permitted to ask any
questions however we're hearing two
bills at the same time so representative
gab you will be permitted to ask
questions of Witnesses in regards to
host till
138 but if you do ask a question please
just specify in regards to 138 just to
make sure everything's
clear
Mr we're gonna keep we're going to keep
the hearing
going at this time the chair recognizes
representative abson introduce House
Bill
Mr chairman I'm not seeing
dis oh no I see it there sorry Mr
chairman yeah he's
on he's unmuted oh are you able to hear
me we can hear you representative all
right thank you I'm sorry about the the
audio situation there uh my name is
representative Max Abramson representing
C Brook Hampton and Hampton Falls I'm
I'm introducing House Bill 138 this is
this the same bill that I introduced
last session um guaranteeing a a uh 25y
year a Pearle hearing at the 25 year
mark um and I want to start by answering
some of the questions that I got last
year that I had to do some research on
um the first question that members of
the committee asked was you know how
many what percentage of people um who go
to a hearing actually get paroled and I
decided to go go ahead and pull up the
numbers from other States um and it's
it's all over the map uh Most states are
in the 20 some per to 30 some perc range
um so most people get a parole hearing
are denied and go back into the system
but they get another shot uh in the
future there were two outliers I believe
Michigan
and um Nevada that had I believe a 69 or
70% um uh parole rate where or release
rate um there are three basic reasons
for putting this in the first reason is
for correctional officer safety and
stress uh as far as why I put it in
after I spoke last session on repeal of
the death penalty literally as I sat
down another member said to me okay well
what about uh safety of correctional
officers and he brought up an
exceptional case what if you have
someone serving life in prison you take
away the death penalty um and now
there's no incentive for an inmate who
might be violent some of the 4,000
inmates there's a small percentage who
are extremely still extremely violent
and should never be released um and what
prevents them from killing a
correctional officer and I thought about
the correctional officer safety first
and then thought about the stress levels
uh I noticed um some years ago that we
were discussing the high stress levels
of Corrections Officers and it's
contributing to a lot of turnout but
it's also causing contributing to a lot
of stress and health problems for those
who are serving in our our prison system
um so I thought well if there's just
even a possibility of a a a parole
hearing somewhere in their future
they're a lot less likely to take the
life of another person another inmate a
visitor or um a correctional uh security
Personnel the second reason that was
brought up brought to my attention I
think after I put the bill in was that
when inmates are very old when they get
into their 60s and
70s uh they develop more and more severe
uh chronic medical conditions um and uh
I'm looking forward into the future not
just under the current uh
pandemic that
um uh they have to have Specialists
coming into the prison well specialist
coming into the prison uh has to take an
entire day off from work in order to to
drive out to the prison and see an
inmate and uh the the costs of those
um those types of visits are extremely
expensive
and they become more and more common as
the as the inmate gets older um more
feeble and as their chronic conditions
get worse um and that's exactly at the
age uh 70-year-old inmates are generally
not statistically a danger to society
even if they may have been a danger when
they were 18 or 20 or 25 certainly when
they're in their 70s uh the chances of
them going out and committing another
violent crime are very very uh slim and
that's part of the reason why parole
boards are much more likely to parole an
inmate who who is much older um and they
do so on second deegree homicide cases
second deegree homicide where it's a
unplanned um either Crime of Passion
spur of the moment or under duress um
manslaughter or second degree they are
getting uh paroled especially if they
are older inmates they have a their a
right to a parole hearing at 18 years
this would just simply guarantee it at
at 25 years and the third reason and I
think the most important reason for me
is the number of wrongful conviction
cases where uh there were some clear-cut
cases when I started investigating New
Hampshire's wrongful conviction cases
but there were some great areas where
even I wasn't certain someone is
maintaining their innocence but uh I'm
only about half certain that they really
were
innocent um I'm not going to name names
but um were there was some evidence of
wrongdoing but maybe not enough to
secure a criminal conviction uh in my
own self-defense case I did a lot of
research on Forensic methods and most if
not all of the forensic methods that
were being used to convict people 25
years ago have been proven to be
completely invalid um Congress
commissioned a study I believe in 2001
that produced a book called
strengthening forensics a path forward
that book didn't come out until
2010 um it's a very worthwhile book I
think it's about
$55 um I think that every member of the
committee should should maybe even every
member of the House should get a copy of
that and see some of the problems that
have existed in in forensics every
single method that they examine from
blood samples hair samples
fingerprints um everything except for
nuclear DNA testing it proven to be um
either invalid uh junk science or needed
to go through additional scrutiny that
you needed to have uh corroboration by
another forensic expert um and one of
the criticisms of Innocence project as
they went through these cases is that
they found that defense
attorneys um often weren't even
cross-examining forensic experts that
forensics methods were once thought to
be irrefutable and unquestionable and
now we know that the the error rates can
be as high as 50 or
60% um for some of them so a a parole
hearing would just kind of be one last
line of defense um it allows human
beings to reopen the case take a look at
evidence that was not heard by the jury
uh in particular evidence that that has
only recently come up become available
um or cases where um
uh where the forensic methods used to
convict people the transcripts were
brought under scr scrutiny after the
trial and found to not be consistent
enough or may not even be admissible in
court
anymore and of course I'll take
questions
thank you representative for your
testimony representative Hopper uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
for uh taking my question I have uh
personally witnessed I think only one
parole hearing and I thought parole
hearings
were um try to determine whether the
parole Le or the uh the
inmate was safe to release into the
public whether they're
Behavior Uh in in prison and things that
they've done in prison justify releasing
those people into the public I is is it
the case that TR hearings are also used
to retry a
case not usually you're you're right
that that is the number one reason that
that they they do psychological
evaluations and they'll even talk to um
people who work in that particular
facility the number one issue that
they're concerned about is is that
have they gone through the reforms that
they need to go through have they done
the work um have they admitted
responsibility for what they've done um
the number one question and I have a
friend in town who worked on the who was
on the parole board for a long time the
number one question on their mind is is
this person safe to go back out into the
community however Pearl boards um people
are allowed to bring in um evidence um
and and
in in particular if you have something
like a I don't know fingerprint or
testimony or some such thing they can
draw attention to that issue and say
well there's there's there's Reasonable
Doubt and and usually it'll be um you
know somebody did actually kill the
person or was present but it wasn't um
it it wasn't at the level that they they
said when when you um negligent homicide
second deegree homicide manslaughter and
other charges if evidence is sometimes
kept out by the judge because the judge
doesn't understand at the time of trial
the the severity of the evidence or they
just sometimes exclude it um because the
defense attorney didn't I guess sell the
witness or explain what the witness was
going to say in enough detail um there
are all kinds of problems and and and
things that happen at trial and the
parole board um does sometimes look at
evidence to see if it's an over
overcharging over sentencing or wrongful
conviction
thank
you thank you thank you representative
and representative the chair would uh
ask to inquire a
question and I want to thank you in
advance for taking my question in
respect to lines n and 10 po
138 it reads that b basically expressly
exclude any person that been sentenced
to uh death the death penalty before the
effective my question is if that
sentence were to be commuted would that
particular uh individual be eligible of
yearses no they wouldn't that's uh I
think we all know who we're talking
about um I I put that in as a
u um personal issue that the um I knew
Michael Briggs and he was a very
professional
model um officer I didn't want this
being used in any particular way to help
his uh killer get out now the bill is in
front of the committee and if the
committee wants to delete that um you
know that's that's your decision but my
preference would be that that the the
killer in question um deserves the
sentence that he got and maybe even
worse thank you for taking my
question representative
Muse thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm curious just
what percentage or or how many people
are currently in the prison system uh
who might be eligible for something like
this um that's actually a good question
um the the methodology used in the bill
the Department of Corrections indicates
that there are 114 individuals that be
eligible for parole before the minimum
sentence and 75 individuals that would
later become eligible for parole review
that are are serving life sentences
without parole so it's a it's a grand
total of about 190
individuals um so it it it's less than
5% of the the prison population but this
is one of those bills that's more of a
matter of uh principle
and yes it's not a very large number but
it it's just the need to have kind of
one last line of defense to have human
beings who um have the the ability to go
ahead and release someone under uh
extraordinary
circumstances represent M you recognize
for a followup question thank you Mr
chair um we heard in testimony on a on a
previous bill which was actually uh in
some ways related uh to this bill um
that one of the reasons for for not
automatically granting a Parole Review
is is that sometimes a prisoner um
simply may not be ready for it um or may
have been violent in prison committed
other offenses um uh and that's one of
the criteria that the parole board uses
uh how does this bill address situations
where uh an inmate May reach this point
but not be um someone that we would
necessarily want to parole back into
society well the parole hearing is only
is only the hearing itself um the the
question of release it's only a minority
of cases Who U where the individual
actually gets released on a first uh
parole
hearing um so if someone who continues
to remain violent in prison or causes
problems or refuses to accept
responsibility or or literally a few of
these people still have the same
attitude 25 years later and those people
are not released um I don't have a
problem with with going through the time
to have that person have a parole
hearing but in that particular case I
think that the benefit of the parole
hearing is to have an an additional
group of people looking at that that
person's case in their their history in
prison and say you know there are other
people who are worthy of release and if
you're going to continue to conduct
yourself this way we're not going to
release you um the the
possibility um even though it's a long
shot the possibility of uh parole and
release um is kind of an incentive that
uh uh the correctional officers and the
ward um sometimes need um in order to
control the population keep the uh keep
the prison itself safe and take some of
those individuals who are serving life
in prison who now you know for a lot of
them they're thinking hey um there's no
reason not to hurt someone there's no
reason not to commit another crime or
even rape or or commit uh uh murder
while they're there if they're facing
life with no possibility of parole there
has to be a slight possibility of parole
there has to be a slight possibility of
release um in order to get them to uh
shape
up thank
you true thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question uh you gave a number of
190 uh people in prison who would
qualify or may eventually qualify
is that
190 uh in prison
for life without
parole yes those are all uh what they
call lwop or life without parole cases
and I believe according to legislative
Services the only type of case uh right
now under state law is is uh capital
murder or first-degree murder I should
say that uh only uh a premeditated
murder um so there would be I think
that's 100 89 cases we get a couple more
every year but uh that's the
number thank
you questions by the
committee thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative
abson is your feeling that percentage
wise there are uh too many prisoners I
mean do we as a whole have too many
prisoners in our prisons uh compared to
other
states uh compared to other states I
think that we have a smaller percentage
but um back in the 1970s we had 200
roughly and now we have about
4,000 uh about a third are serving time
for victimless crimes a little more than
a third um and actually a large
percentage are just people awaiting
hearings or waiting trial um
one of the people working at the public
defenders office said that they they had
a client who'd been in there for three
and a half years um who had not even had
their trial and that the case just kept
getting kicked down the road so a large
percentage of the people who were in
Corrections uh haven't even been found
guilty yet so but on on the bigger issue
on the bigger question are there too
many people in in prison yes um but for
the first
degree um first degree homicide
population I would I would view them as
separate and um I think that frankly
most of them deserve to be in prison um
and the parole hearing that I'm
proposing is just uh an incentive to try
to keep the U uh keep the Corrections
Officers safer and and get uh get
inmates to reform themselves turn
themselves
around thank
you there any other question by the
[Music]
committee
thank you very much for your testimony
all right thank you and I'll send you
folks an email on the uh parole
statistics I was
mentioning Mr chairman yes um would you
mind if I called Donna scitech and Then
followed with u former chairman John th
sounds acceptable to me right thank you
Mr
chairman yeah
I'm going
back
testifying on house bille 598
I yeah uh good morning again Mr chairman
and members of the committee I'm Donna
scitec uh I'm appearing on my own
behalf uh for part of one of these bills
and on behalf of the parole board uh in
opposition to both of these
bills
uh while it's fresh in your mind I want
to clarify some things uh the parole
board does not retry a case we don't
look at new evidence we look merely at
the criteria for parole uh as I have to
tell victims uh many times who come to
parole hearings that we are not a
resentencing body the judge who's heard
all the information and has heard from
the victims imposed a sentence that he
thought was just so
uh don't use this as a way as an
alternate way of appealing your case as
far as our parole rate uh New Hampshire
has one of the highest parole rates in
the country we parole about 85% of the
people that we
hear uh and the other thing is the
prison population is about 2,000 it has
been declining we have 500 fewer than we
had a year
ago uh and the reference to people
languishing in jail the preach there are
no pre-trial detainees at the state
prison those are Folks at the
county so to just to clarify that so
back to my personal reason for opposing
uh
138 is that it violates truth and
sentencing uh anybody who knows me who's
been around the legislature for a long
time as I have and perhaps
representative Welch knows that I am the
mother of Truth and
sentencing there was a case of a
murderer in
1983 who was given a life sentence and
he ended up being eligible for parole
after 10 years and there was a hue and
cry petitions we had throngs of people
at the hearing and as a result of that
we came up with our policy of Truth and
sentencing that means that the the
minimum of the sentence that imposed by
the judge is the amount that is served
before they're eligible for parole this
was to inspire confidence in the
criminal justice system so that a
sentence of two to four meant that a
person would be sentenced to would serve
at least two years before they're
eligible for parole unless the judge
modified their
sentence uh I'm and looking at 598 where
it says uh life without parole
actually means life with
parole I'm thinking of Allison
Wonderland when Humpty Dumpty said when
I use a word it means what I want it to
me neither more or neither more or less
um this house bill 138 would make the
minimum sentence meaningless if the
judge imposed two to four what does the
two
mean if the goal is to motivate people
to change their behavior there are
already existing provisions of the law
that allow them to to have opportunities
to get their sentence reduced rather
than across the board 50% discount on
all the sentences without requiring some
evidence of of effort on their part Uh
current RSA 5120 allows an inmate to ask
the court for a reduction of Maximum
after they serve 2third of their
sentence so it's already on the books if
they serve 2third of the minimum they
can go back to the judge and they can
make their case that they should be
eligible for parole this happens um
practically everybody asks for a
two-thirds reduction uh a decent number
of them are granted it they also uh
often as part of the sentencing the
judge will build into the sentence a
provision that if they are engage in a
particular program for example the
in-house drug treatment program which is
called Focus they would be eligible for
six months or uh one year off their
minimum but in the all these in these
cases it's the judge who is modifying
the sentence so that complies with truth
and sentencing the sentence imposed by
the judge is the sentence that's served
also uh the judge can authorize the
awarding of earn time credit uh the
legislature has uh provided that certain
that the commissioner can
award credit 60 120 days depending on
what program for educational behavioral
health or parenting programs is spelled
out in the legislature but as as this
bill is
introduced it it's the third reason that
I'm opposed to it is that it's too broad
it applies to all
crimes everything
uh from you know the most minor felonies
to to uh to to murder it applies to all
crimes if you think sentences are too
harsh you should change the the
penalties that are set out in the
statute you could do it one by one
you've already done this regarding the
penalties for marijuana but rather to
rather than painting all crimes with a
broad brush and saying you get a 50%
discount
um I I think is
misguided uh and also flies in the face
of changing the sentence after the judge
has imposed it the judge who's heard all
the facts and listen to all the
victims further the bill presents some
logistical hurdles for the parole board
if this applies to all it isn't clear
from the bill whether it applies to
those currently incarcerated or just
people coming in new if it applies to
everybody incarcerated we're going to
have to double the number of our parole
hearings we are already busy um with
fully booked on Tuesdays and Thursdays
uh for all day hearings and the hearings
require 15 20 hours of
preparation so um that that's a lot to
ask of members of the parole board uh if
it applies only prospectively you're
going to have some people in the prison
who are eligible for parole at 50% and
some that are serving their full minimum
it's just it's a problem as a practical
matter the parole board won't release
anybody who hasn't completed their
programs or who has a terrible
disciplinary record so you're getting
people's hopes up and if they haven't
completed the recommended programs for
example for drug treatment or mental
health uh uh anger management if they
haven't completed their programs we ar
going to give them parole
anyway because our primary goal is
Public Safety and people who have not
comp completed their recommended
programs are a bigger threat to Public
Safety um than than people who do commit
who do uh complete their program
programs so I would urge you to report
both bills as inexpedient to legislate
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
you
have has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question there there was something that
you said that is really ringing in my
ears and I think it was along the lines
of a person that is serving a life
sentence well I guess really it's only
going to be half of that before they're
eligible for PE so really what is going
on so with that being said can you maybe
give us an
example
of I I know that you're necessarily not
that person would be feeling this but
given what you do you know for a living
for a maybe an example of for a family
that has a family member that was the
victim of one of these crimes that is so
horrendous is the person who's put been
put in prison for life and now because
25 years come along they're they're
they're eligible for parole what would
that be like for a family to have to
continue you know to relive the
nightmare all over again when they
thought they at least had some some kind
of closure to give involment their life
I can tell you that for victims of
crimes serious crimes even burglaries um
when the victims come in every time
there is a parole hearing it's like the
crime was committed yesterday
they have to revisit all those emotions
it is so painful for the victims who
have to come in and appear at a parole
hearing and in many cases the uh inmate
isn't going to be ready for parole and
so they are entitled to another
hearing uh within six months if they
denied parole
and every
time that there is a parole hearing the
victims uh have to relive the
trauma with regard to changing the the
sentence I can remember a case where a a
young girl had been victimized by her
neighbor she she had been
repeatedly uh
raped the sentence that they worked
out uh to avoid a trial was a negotiated
plea the
inmate the offender was sent
to a certain amount of time so that he
would not be eligible for role until she
was away at College in between the
legislature enacted these earn time
credits so the guy was eligible for
parole before she went away to college
and I can't tell you how traumatic that
was for for the for the girl and for her
family so I'm glad you brought up the
effect that this kind of policy change
would have on victims because it is real
there any other oh repres has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you very much
for taking my question
[Music]
um you you admit I believe you said that
in New Hampshire 85% of prisoners get
paroled by that
sentence are you saying that
85% don't serve their
maximum right the the uh the sentencing
policy in New Hampshire is they uh
impose a minimum and a maximum they are
eligible for parole at their
minimum
so
85 I don't have the exact numbers but
it's it's very high compared to NA
national standards 85% of the people
will hear will hear on a given Thursday
will be granted
parole uh that may be because they were
they met all the criteria by the time of
their minimum a lot of them will
postpone their hearing knowing that we
would deny them until they completed
programs and so they'll wait until their
programs are completed uh to apply for
parole so we would be
uh we don't parole everybody we don't
parole 85% at their exact minimum we
parole about 85% of the people who come
before us some are at their minimum some
are a little beyond their minimum some
waited uh because they needed to find
housing needed to complete a program but
of the cases we hear a large number are
granted
parole can I answer your question yes
ma'am I do have thank you Mr chair I do
have one more question man' if you would
take it um because I don't understand
how the Pool Works
um prisoners must serve their minimum
sentence so for example in a in a two to
four sentence your sentence two to four
years
um so okay so two to four means they're
eligible for parole at the two-year spot
the
two-year
point it means that if they're released
then they are on parole for until four
years so two years behind the walls two
years in the community under parole
supervision
question thank you ma'am so my question
would be if they if they earn a whole
bunch of uh time off
credits does that reduce them uh for uh
for it changes their
minimum it changes their minimum a lot
of times the judge will say if you
complete the focus program you can have
a year off and so they uh have a a 3 to
six they complete the focus program
there their sentence changes to 2 to
six thank thank you
ma'am but this is all done with with the
judge's approval just
to be consistent with the policy that
the sentence imposed by the the minimum
sentence imposed by the judge is a
sentence is actually
served
I'm
sorry
no thank you Mr chair um and uh thank
you to uh speaker s say for for taking
my question um in situations like murder
without parole or murder sentences with
additional penalties of crimes um there
appears to be no minimum in that case
and are are people in that
situation not uh
uh not eligible for parole or to apply
for parole even though they may have um
completed all of the
requirements um and maybe even got
degrees and are helpful at the prison
and whatever and maybe even the victim's
family is in would be in favor of the
parole if it was asked for
could you just comment on that
possibility somebody is uh serving a
life without
parole they can't get it reduced unless
they go back to the judge for a sentence
reduction they don't get the benefit of
earn time
credits and would that
followup and that would also be the case
for someone who
has a murder sentence and do all murder
sentences that are had that um do not
include the part about no eligibility
for parole do they have a minimum
sentence always associated with that
life sentence yeah thank you very much
yes they do thank
you con thank you Mr chairman thank you
speaker so if we've heard today that 85%
of New Hampshire inmates are for that
suggests to me this is a useful
inducement for good behavior and
reform uh and trying to better on do
that same standard apply to inmates
serving life without parole do you feel
as though that that would be uh the kind
of inducement to dis behave themselves
some kind of hope that uh they could
maybe be
L the the parole board is not a
resentencing body we just abide by the
sentence imposed by the judge uh as an
observation uh lifers tend not to be
disciplinary
problems it's surprising people who are
doing life without parole who are
serving long sentences are not
disciplinary problems and surprisingly
sex offenders are not disciplinary
problems
generally sex offenders have to usually
plan their life so they they they know
how to control their behavior because
had to groom their victims in many cases
so that that was a a surprise to me they
aren't the disciplinary problems the
disciplinary problems of the younger
people who were there for drugs and
burglaries and theft by unauthorized
taking
assaults question thank you Mr chairman
and thank you uh for taking this
unrelated follow um you mentioned
earlier
uh a case that seemed to Spur New
Hampshire's truth and
sentencing uh
changes um is there more to it than that
or did that one case uh encourage the
law to change in New Hampshire is there
more to truth and sentencing changes in
New Hampshire or is it just a single
case the impetus for truth and
sentencing was the potential release of
Edward kulage
who had murdered Pamela
Mason
um murdered and raped her and threw her
body in the maram river it was an
outrageous crime that terrorized the
community because there had been a
number of other similar murders of
teenage
babysitters
um and when he was be he was given a
life
sentence life at that time meant uh 18
years he had accumulated I I believe you
know 8 years of pre-trial credit or
something uh anyway he was eligible for
release about 10 years after he he went
to the prison the family was outraged
the community was outraged there were
petitions that were presented to the
Judiciary Committee which used to have
uh jurisdiction over criminal justice
issues uh I was chairman of the
committee at the time um
there there was a demand that we do
something about this and the answer was
truth and sentencing so that the
sentence imposed would be the sentence
served and they said well where is the
incentive for them to behave themselves
if they just have to serve their their
minimum we put in a provision and this
is in every mimus um your sentence to
two to four and to the sentence is added
150 days of disciplinary time which they
work off off at 12 and a half days a
month so instead of giving a discount
for good behavior we add on for bad
behavior so somebody who escapes loses
all his uh the 150 days that he had uh
might have earned off the The Sur charge
on the sentence if you
want thank you on
Bradley you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um do you have any um data about the
impact of Truth and sentencing on the
New Hampshire
population I'm sorry I couldn't I
couldn't hear you the audio wasn't very
good sorry can you hear me now that's
better okay sorry um do you have any
data about the impact of Truth and
sentencing on the New Hampshire
population oh it certainly increased the
uh prison
population significantly we thought at
the time that the judges would modify
their sentences to reflect that
everybody had to serve their minimum the
judges didn't do that so our prison
population uh did grow
significantly thank
you thank you chair uh thank you for
taking my question
um so if someone comes up for parole and
they are not granted parole uh when's
the next time they can apply for parole
uh when they are not granted parole we
have to give them a reason we denied
them and they have to meet certain
conditions okay we're denying your
parole today because you don't have a
solid housing plan come back to us when
you've got a solid housing plan we're
denying you parole today because you
haven't completed the focus program come
back to us when you are close to
completion of the focus program so we
have to give them a reason and when they
meet that the criteria that we said they
can come back before the
board followup followup question thank
you chair thank you taking my question
um if we were to double the number of
probe uh hearings uh how would uh you
handle
that I don't know they have to add
another day of
hearings just one
day yeah we hear about 25 cases a
day and right now the uh parole board
members are paid $100 a
day uh the preparation for a day of
hearings is you know
15 15 maybe 20 hours of preparation and
then you spend the whole
day for 100
bucks didn't we I'm saying that to
people who make $100 a year I recognize
that
thank you uh I thought that we made uh
adjustments to uh the proboard uh uh
compensation last that was that uh that
was part of the bill that died is not
part of this bill uh part of the U House
Bill two makes a complete change to the
the structure and compensation of the
parole board but that's in House Bill
too right now we're at 100 100 $ $100 a
day thank you very much in order to
prepare for an extra day of hearings it
would require a lot more staff time to
prepare all the packets all the
information we need we typically we
could get you know 75 or 100 Pages for
each of the cases that we have to read
so they have to assemble all that data
for us and then provide it and we have
to read
it thank you
see representa Muse you
recognized yes thank you for taking my
question um one of the things that we
heard uh last year when we reviewed the
results of the audit was that there were
a lot of inefficiencies in the parole
board a lot of them were budget related
um a lot of them were resource related
um related to not having enough staff
uh one of the things I'm I guess I guess
that I'm curious about is that
if if there was a way to actually make
the parole board more uh efficient and
maybe some of the things in in House
Bill 2 uh are targeted at doing that but
if there was a way to do that uh would
there would you still have the same
degree of concern with uh the increased
number of of cases in the case load the
reason for killing these bills isn't
because of the increased workload on on
the parole board the reason for killing
them is is that it's a bad policy House
Bill 2 uh proposes a uh dramatic change
in the in the structure and the
operation of the board uh it makes a
full-time paid chairman uh gives us an
extra person in the office to help
prepare all the information we need to
make a parole decision and uh increases
the uh salary to to of the board
members thank
you see seeing no further hands raised I
want to thank Madam speaker s for her
testimony at this time the chair
recognizes the The Honorable John
[Music]
all thank you Mr chairman can you hear
me all
right good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is John ethal
Jr I live in Whitefield New Hampshire I
appear today as opposition to House Bill
598 as a retired New Hampshire State
Police Chief Sergeant chief of police
current part-time C County deputy
sheriff and have had the honor of
serving as a member and former chair of
the criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee and currently serve as a
member of New Hampshire parole
board however I appear today not as a
member of those organizations but as a
victim of crime representing myself and
my
family my sister-in-law was shot to
death in 2004 she was executed while
sitting at a breakfast table by her
adopted son who shot her in the back of
the head with a gun he had sto stolen
the night before from his
grandfather he then Reloaded The Gun put
his spent cartridge in his pocket stole
her money jewelry and took off in a car
he was captured in Western New York
where he ran a toll
booth he pleed guilty and was sentenced
to 25 to life for second deegree murder
although I believe the facts supported a
first deegree this bill would allow him
to seek Pat parole after only two 12 and
a half years while that period has
already elapsed he would be able to
request par
immediately I do not know the
committee's already been told about the
Senate reduction hearings with the uh
the judge justices by uh representative
speaker scitec and uh this particular
individual individual has already
requested such a hearing and was denied
after review by the
judge if this bill should pass it will
traumatize my entire family many of whom
are deathly afraid of this person many
other victims of crime will be simly
affected by this bill should it pass and
I humbly ask you to vote this bill is
inexpedient to
legislate thank you very
much thank you for your
testimony uh Mr chairman I just I just
recalled something else uh on uh
representative aon's Bill he talked
about elderly members who are having
problems and things uh it wasn't
mentioned but there is such thing as a
medical parole for those people who are
uh deemed to be uh necessary of of
extreme treatment
Etc seeing No Hands raised I want to
thank the witness first testimony thank
you Mr
chairman attendance reflected represent
now
attend for any members of the public who
are who wish to testify that are in
attendance please U raise your hands at
this
time the chair now recognizes Jay
Macky can everyone hear me yes we can
hear uh good morning honorable members
of the committee and thank you for
taking my testimony on this bill my name
is Jay Macky I'm administrator of
classifications and client records at
the New Hampshire Department of
Corrections I'm speaking on behalf of
the department in opposition to House
Bill 598 I have submitted written
testimony regarding our position I'll
Briefly summarize uh our reasons for
this although speaker scitech had
actually uh kind of stole a lot of the
Thunder that I was going to present so
I'll will try not to reiterate
everything that she said um in regards
to truth and sentencing currently the
offenders are required to complete 100%
of their minimum but due to earn time
credit laws and also six RSA 65120 they
allowed to get their sentences their
minimum and maximum sentences reduced
six months ago RSA 651a 22A for earn
time credit was just expanded to allow
for many more opportunities for uh
residents to apply for earn time credit
they can get up to 21 months or 630 days
of earn time credit against their
sentence um a lot more of programming is
available now that we have tablets uh
Correctional Research Institute where
they can get 60 days for some programs
completed as well as multiple vocational
programs where before they could only
get it one time reduction um if passed
household 598 would have a drastic
impact on the ability of our department
to provide recommended programming for
the residents prior to being eligible
for
parole for the most part most of the
residents go into their intensive
programs whether it be the focus program
as scitec spoke about or the sex Fender
treatment program they don't go into
those programs till about two years to
their minimum due to needing those
skills that they learn in the programs
to apply to their re-entry into society
um currently if if this bill is passed
we would we would be able to provide
that programming without a major
increase in staff um or areas of
programming to be available to
us um we would recommend this bill be
sent to a study committee on truth and
sentencing which was proposed last year
in Senate Bill
438 um I can take any questions that
anyone has uh even following up for
questions they had for Miss sitech as
well thank you for your testimony the
chair recogniz it representative B thank
you Mr chairman and thank you sir for um
taking my
question uh the last speaker
mentioned uh
medical reasons for having your sentence
reduced in the hundreds of emails I
got um that was sent you know with
people's names on it from a certain
group U they mentioned the high cost of
medical is that possible for you know
somebody that's elderly and has major
health issues to get
released yes thank you for the question
um medical parole is an option it is I
don't want to say few and far between
but it is not as common as there are a
lengthy process that is started by the
medical department at the doc um when
they have to vet the amount the
treatment going to cost in addition to
um if this individual is going to be a
danger to society If released and then
that all gets uh put together and you
know the parole board here is for
medical parole and my current position
I've been in it for about three years I
have
seen maybe two or three people relas
leased on medical
parole um it's it's not as common but it
is something that that is done thank
you representative poer thank you Mr
chair thank you uh for taking my
question um because of Co I know that
some of the programs in in J and prison
are not available such as 12 step
programs are the programs aailable to
inmates to actually complete the
prerequisites before they're eligible
for Paro or could successfully get roll
because of
co uh thank you for the question uh
currently right now we did have two
Focus programs for drug treatment the
Intensive drug treatment program running
one in conquete and one up in the burin
facility uh due to staffing issues we
had to temporarily suspend the one in
conquered and we are currently moving
anyone on the list for focus is up to uh
the Berlin facility so they can complete
it in a timely manner due to the opioid
epidemic that we've been dealing with
for the past few years the list for
focus is extremely high um a lot of
parole violators come back and are
assessed for needing intensive treatment
and due to not completing it in the in
the community um failing drug court
other issues they need to complete that
prior to being released so they kind of
take a a jump ahead of some of these
other individuals that are sentenced
instead of pro violators so but we do
have programs running sex offender
treatment programs running our intensive
programs are all running I can't speak
to some of the minor level of programs
that we do have but I know that they are
um still doing a lot of programs that
we've had available in the
past thank
you representative
news thank you Mr chair um and thank you
for taking my question um um one of the
things that I'm curious about is the
potential uh impact of uh of this year's
Budget on some of the programs that
you're referring to uh so my
understanding is that last week uh
commissioner Hanks uh testified in front
of the finance committee that uh a
couple of the halfway houses uh and some
of the educational programs for inmates
uh would need to be would need to be
shut down and I guess if a reason to
keep people uh in prison and so they can
take these programs the assump the
assumption would be that the programs
would need to be there uh so that they
could be completed so what I'm what I'm
curious about is are any of the programs
that uh that people would need to to to
take as a or complete as a as a
condition of release uh basically under
Threat by the current
budget uh I would thank you for the
question I would would currently say no
because most of the programs that are
required by the parole board are our the
Intensive programs that we still have
running um there are alternatives to
some of the Lesser ones like anger
management there you know before I came
to the doc that was an full Anger
Management program that has been more of
a one-on-one or a smaller group so to
speak that they complete I know and
unfortunately if that does come to pass
that the half the halfway houses get
closed um so our residents that were in
the halfway houses on work release are
taking AER Management in the community
while they're on work release to be able
to have that uh when they go up for
parole thank
you seeing no further hands raised the
witness is excused I want to thank you
for your
testimony thank you chel recognizes
Donna
Brown hi hello this is attorney Donna
Brown in Manchester I am speaking today
on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense
attorneys I myself have been a criminal
defense attorney for over 30 years uh a
great uh part of that time was as a
public defender uh after the last five
or six years I've been in private
practice um uh I found it very
interesting to listen to the other Donna
Donna scitec today and I I agreed with a
lot of what she said except for the
result I I should clarify I am only
speaking today on behalf of how House
Bill 598 at which is regarding truth and
sentencing and I don't plan to address
uh the uh change in the call them lwop
or lifer bill so I'm only going to
address uh uh the the basically repeal
of of Truth and sent sentencing uh
there's there's a saying that's been
around for a long time that say hard
cases make bad law um and you can I can
think of a hundred cases I remember when
the legislature moved the juvenile age
from 18 down to 17 it was one really bad
case um and but the you know
99% of juvenile cases should have stayed
or n you know 90% of 17y olds should
have been addressed in the uh in the
juvenal justice system and not the um
adult system and that was changed
several years back to make it back to to
18 and you know there's lots of cases
attorney I mean attorney uh a pro board
member scitech talked about the Edward
coolage case um another uh person who
testified talked about another murder uh
but the overwhelming majority of the
people that would be affected by this
would be uh inmates who committed um
nonviolent offenses uh and and that's
why you know in order to avoid someone
like Edward kulage getting out early New
Hampshire decided we're going to
increase our prison population from 200
to several thousand in the course of a
few decades and so that's what happens
is this kind of one-size fits all of of
you know we're we're always going to be
looking at the the terrible murder case
and we're not going to fix the issue
with the with the other inmates and and
I would suggest that there's ways to
address that I I do agree with um uh
Pearl board member scitec that um cases
aren't retried uh in fact I would I
would strongly recommend it against
anyone going to the PE board and saying
I'm innocent they got the wrong guy but
let me out that doesn't usually work too
well uh but uh usually the there there
is some relevance though to the
underlying crime and that is that if you
went to prison for horrific violent or
sexual or both type of crime the pl
board wants to make sure you're not that
same person anymore that you whatever
LED you to do that be it drugs or uh
some defect that that you've done
something about that uh and so that's
what I you know that's how that does
come into the plle board and I've been
to plle board hearings for people who
have had convictions for second deegree
murder as I think someone explained
earlier you don't get Paro for first
deegree murder but for second degree
murder you do and those are you know
usually they last an hour an hour and a
half usually the Attorney General's
office comes to those hearings with the
victim Advocate with um many times
family members um from the victim there
there there there are separate type of
Ro hearing for those hearings but the
that I I say that because it's important
to remember and I know it's been said
already that there there is a second
step that by changing um truth and
sentencing you're not letting people out
all you're doing is changing parole
eligibility so if you if you did have
someone who you lowered um the the time
the period of time from when they could
come before the P Board there's still
going to be notification of the victim's
family there's still going to be a
chance to object and and and as I said
almost every hearing I've had um the um
prosecution has said here's something
about the crime that you parole board
should know in deciding whether he's
ready to go back into the community so
those things are addressed um as I I
said I Our concern is that we'll we'll
we'll focus on one or two horrific
crimes to the to not looking at the vast
majority of cases where this would
benefit the community where this would
would benefit families um uh and be the
more fiscally responsible thing to do as
as well as the right thing to do um one
thing I've seen over the years over and
over and over that when when you give
someone a long sentence and the only the
people who get long sentences aren't
just you know people charged with rape
or sexual assault and murder um there
are some uh drug offenses there are
people doing 10 years on uh drug
offenses and when you put someone in
prison for that long of time you're
really increasing the chance that their
children will grow up in poverty that
their children will not have child
support that their children will not
have uh a father um who is on the
outside to uh help them uh you know
monetarily whether they're in the family
or not so um the cost isn't the extra
you know couple thousand of people that
are in the prison the cost uh goes
throughout our society in terms of of uh
helping children um who aren't going to
have at least one parent who can help
with the cost of their them being raised
um and I think that is all I have to say
and if anyone has any questions I I
would love to answer
them see your hands raised I want to
thank witness Mr chair see I'm trying to
get my video up thank you repres when
you haven't been recognized you're
speaking out of
order
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
thank the witness for
Testimony the chair now recognizes
Joseph thank thank you very much can you
hear me
speak thank you committee and chair for
hearing my testimony
today lask and I will be representing
the American civil liberties Union of
New Hampshire in support of HB
598 and I urge this committee to vote a
to pass on this
legislation as we've heard um throughout
the 70s all the way up to the 90s the US
adopted this punishment only um get
tough on crime perspective towards uh
policies in the criminal justice system
and we did see things like the three
strikes laws mandatory minimums and
truth and sentencing and when truth and
sentencing was first enacted in uh 1984
but New Hampshire enacted in 1982 it
required states to increase the length
of prison time if person was
incarcerated for and prove that they had
served no less than an 85% minimum
portion of their sentence established by
federal
guidelines um with the passage of Truth
and sentencing things like parole
eligibility and good in good time
credits um were restricted and in some
cases effectively
eliminated the original Federal truth
and sentencing guidelines required only
an 85% of minimums to be served however
um New Hampshire decided to distinguish
Itself by adopting the harshest and most
extreme version of this policy 100% um
across the board truth and sentencing is
a onrack minded policy that impedes
Rehabilitation it is punitive oriented
it requires people to serve a blanket
percentage across the board regardless
if they're rehabilitated or not and it
doesn't Foster an environment that would
be conducive to individuals changing the
behavior that even landed them in prison
I know one concern um that has come up
is that HB 598 would open the floodgates
of the prison system and everyone would
be let out and I and I just want to make
it very clear this bill does not do that
all HB 598 does is allow a person to
have a hearing before the New Hampshire
Adult Parole Board and have them make an
informed decision about whether or not
to Grant the privilege of
parole this this means a lot to me
because you know I I I don't know what
it's like to you know be a a legislator
or to to write laws or whatnot but what
I do know is the effects of policies I
myself have served 13 years incarcerated
in the New Hampshire prison system I
have seen um every aspect of the parole
I have seen um
how
Rehabilitation um is fostered and how it
gets snuffed out and I can tell you that
truth and sentencing as it is this
policy does not promote Rehabilitation
and is anti- um what we are looking for
for re-entering Society members I wanted
to just address like just a couple of
the concerns that we heard about 85% of
people will be granted um parole that
goes in front of the parole board uh
that does not that number it doesn't
represent individuals getting parole on
their minimum and one of the biggest
things is having to wait for your
programs to be completed which will take
people over their minimum sentences
so one there's not a truth in the
sentencing that you're getting because
you're not that the time that you're
doing that you're sentenced to as a
minimum oftentimes is not the time that
you end up doing and when we look at
this you know we were we were told that
this is oh
oh uh the time that you're sentenced to
that is the time that um you know you're
going to do but you're adding bad time
to a sentence that mentality means that
you're automatically assuming people who
are going to the prison system are going
to continue that behavior that type of
mentality and that message does not
promote Rehabilitation and it does not
it doesn't Foster it at all and the
provision about the 2/3 um being granted
parole that you know we heard that
everyone asks for ask for it everyone
does ask for it because everyone wants
to have a hope they want something to
believe in and the truth is very few
people get a two-thirds granted because
you're petitioning the court you're
petitioning a sentencing judge who only
saw the facts of your case that sent you
to prison you're asking that individual
to review what you've done and be
granted parole often times people do not
get a two3
sentence
and I know that this this bill was is is
is said to you know Inspire confidence
but this bill does not Inspire
confidence truth and sentencing does not
Inspire confidence in the system it
really only makes the system look
extreme and
inhumane and and and the reason why it
does that is you the earn time credit
system that is there a judge has to
approve that on a minimum sentence
because if they don't a person would
have to file go through this whole
process of filing a motion just to even
get the um the earn time credits and
there is great there is a reason to have
concern over that because of the budget
of the the the budget announcement the
earn time credit system is pretty much
built on every single program that would
be effectively cut from the budget um if
if if that is what is is is happens and
I can and I can speak to that um more
this is not going to double parole
hearing in the sense that it's the same
amount of people who would be going up
for parole whether you're doing it at
50% of your minimum or you're doing it
at 100% it's still the same amount of
people that would be getting parole so
it's not going to double the amount of
parole hearings it's just going to make
people eligible to go in front of the
parole board and see if they've been
rehabilitated and meet the requirements
of
parole we
heard talking about the um the Intensive
programs that um that are running that
are that are used if the Intensive
programs are the only things that are
used to gauge um the rehabilitative
nature of a person then I I really
caution what we are doing when when we
are looking at how people are ending up
in front of the parole board without um
completing educational um programs and
and how they are rehabilitated we have
to see that individuals need to be given
a chance to continue that growth instead
of remaining in environment that is
going to pull them in the opposite
direction nothing about prison
intrinsically will push people towards
Rehabilitation you have to go get it
yourself and that has to be
incentivized and for these reasons and
many more that I support HP 598 I am
happy to take any and all questions that
anyone may
have thank you for your
testimony representative
Newman thank you Mr
chair and thank you to the witness for
taking my
question um we've heard testimony about
parole and we've heard testimony about
resentencing hearings would you uh
please um tell me uh what your views are
from your
experience on whether you have a
preference for one of those over the
other thank
you excuse me represent could you just
repeat that just one if I have a
preference for what which one we've
heard follow may I
clarify you recognize the clarify a
question thank you Mr chair uh yes we
have heard testimony about parole and
we've heard testimony about resentencing
hearings and I would just like to know
if you have a preference of one of those
over the other as in order um to
accomplish um people being um whatever
thank you very much for your question uh
represent um yes I do have a preference
I of parole and the reason why is when
you do a resentencing hearing first of
all now you are taking on um petitioning
a court
system and that that's going to that's
going to have a financial cost to both
um the state who has to um represent um
you know the state's interest in that
uh it's a financial cost to the
individual who is um putting in the
motion and often times people don't have
of the financial resources to to
petition a court to say hey I really
think that I qualify for being
rehabilitated based on what I've done
when you have parole what happens is
you're you're not always granted parole
and what what happens is they get to
they get to view things differently they
get to see a more detailed um report and
a more detailed uh record of what you
have done during your incarceration um
sentence to to be granted parole I could
speak for myself personally um during
the first eight years of my sentence I I
was not the um I wasn't the ideal um or
model inmate by far by a long
shot and the parole board treated me as
such when I when the last five years of
my sentence after I had um become became
rehabilitated and I had changed I
changed my behavior and it and it showed
the parole board was able to make that
determination and was able to comment on
the the the steps that I had taken they
were able to see it they were able to
talk about it and to and say this is
what we are looking for this is what we
are trying to do I mean the pull parole
hearing was recorded So I I personally
feel and what I've seen that being able
to go in front of the parole board to
make your case and to have that heard um
is much better because then you then you
know what you're working on you know
okay well I can go back in front of them
if I work on this and and and it's a
wakeup call then trying to spend money
to go back in front of a court to get a
court hearing and and go through that
whole
process thank you very
much representative B you recognize for
a question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um if we pass
598 uh and um someone has sentenced a 3
to six year uh uh
term and they get off with half of the
minimum serve my understanding from
testimony earlier today they would be uh
on parole for the next four and a half
years uh what is life like on parole is
it really uh uh much better than
prison it is a world it is a Universe um
different than being in prison from
being on parole when so I'm I'm
currently on parole and I will be on
parole for the next five years and my
journey has revealed so many things that
I I did not know um or subtle
differences um to be able to wake just
just something so simple as to be able
to wake up and look out your window and
not see a 35t tall barb wire wall but to
see maybe a tree or outside that is a
big difference and what that does is
that
inspires connection to the community
that that's a reinforcement I have moved
past prison I am now in the community I
am going to continue doing the right
thing right something so small as that
being on parole means that you are still
being held accountable and that you have
structure to
continue the rehabilitative journey that
you have started I have I have to you
know I have to check in with my parole
officer I have to let him know
everything that I'm doing I have to uh
ask his permission to to do things but
he also sets goals you know you could
see while you've been working for this
many months straight you have done this
you have been um of good behavior you
get that you get that relationship um
where you are your parole officer is
there to encourage you and push you in
the right direction because you've made
parole prison does is that's not their
job they're only there to make sure that
they keep security and that you do your
requirements it becomes the difference
between being on parole and being in
prison is one is transactional when
you're in prison you are solely a number
you're referred to by a number that is
it you are not a human you are a number
your parole officer is to humanize you
because you have been rehabilitated and
to continue that
growth thank you representative BT you
were recognized for a question thank you
Mr chairman and thank you uh for your
testimony um you stated that
if uh the
prisoner uh no if programs you know that
the prisoners take or assigned to them
are are not completed within their
sentence that they will not be granted
parole do you have any statistics or you
know paperwork that you could show that
that's the case where you know people
that are not completing you know do not
qualify for
perole uh yeah it's it's on it's a
parole requirement um that is a that is
a doc and uh and I believe a court
requirement when the court sentences you
to um to prison they will put it on your
Minimus so it'll be on your on your
Minimus it will have a a specific um uh
order from the judge which will say you
have to complete
uh the focus program during your
incarceration or what the judge may say
is you must complete any and all Doc
required programming and what that means
is then the doc can say well we're going
to do an assessment on you when you
first come in and and this happens in
R&D when you first come in within the
first 30 to 45 days of your sentence
what they do is they'll do an assessment
um mental health assessment they're
going to they're going to look at um
your crime if you need to see a laid act
they're going to do all these types of
Assessments to develop what type of pro
uh uh a prison plan pretty much that you
must follow in order to be eligible for
parole so it's going to look different
for each person but one of the main
requirements that is thematic for
everyone is that they have to complete
whatever programs the doc or the court
has
required thank
you
seeing no further hands raised I want to
thank the witness for his testimony the
witness is
excused CH recognizes
evanor the initial P just please State
your full name for the record where
you're from and whe and whether you're
testifying in support of opposition to
either House Bill 598 or House Bill 138
or
both okay
yes my name is evanor
Panetta
I'm testifying in support of the bill I
am a resident of Nashville New Hampshire
um born and raised in Nashville New
Hampshire I was formally incarcerated I
was in prison for 15 years I've been
released for the
past nine months
and and again I'm I'm I'm testifying on
my own behalf as a a private citizen for
HB
598 and I've been listening to um a lot
of what's been said you know there's a
lot of back and forth um this is nothing
new you know uh I know Donna saitech was
uh uh um has been in support of Truth
and sentencing for such a long time and
as she saids she is the mother of the of
the bill um but I just feel that you
know in the past last three and a half
four decades a lot has changed and not
for the best um you
know statistics if you want to look at
numbers the population of prison you
know back in 83 was you know around 300
and since then the prison population in
New Hampshire has risen I think 600% and
I think we lead that in the country um
doesn't seem you
know we're at what 20 500 roughly
inmates in the prison population numbers
have been trending down
lately um but some of that can be
attributed to the epidemic as of the
past year as to why those numbers are
trending down and the fact of the matter
is you know programs are threatened um
there's cases where you may go to parole
and originally when you were sentenced
you were supposed to do certain programs
I can speak personally I was supposed to
do a couple different programs that over
the years were eliminated so I never
even had the opportunity to participate
in these programs and it didn't affect
me at the end when I was
parols um I'm also a person that was uh
had filed for two-thirds reduction the
65120 bill I was eligible for six years
I got two um and I'm super you know
grateful that I got anything because in
most cases a lot people a lot of people
do not get any time any relief no matter
you know how much they've done over the
years to improve themselves and I know
of guys that you know they had they got
master's degrees and got very little
relief if any um also the earn time
credit bill it has its flaws you know
again some of those programs are now in
the chopping block with the new budget
that the uh Governor is proposing and
cutting a lot of the education and and
programming and I think that's the worst
thing that we could possibly do you know
New Hampshire has such great potential
to be able to you know do something
different for their inate population
given the you know the small number um a
lot of the you know uh local schools
that you know we could potentially get
involved I mean that's a whole another
subject but uh I just think
motivation um you know incentive is so
important and and I'm going to try to
make this really quick so the
best analogy I could make is you know
the way sentencing is now it's kind of
like socialism you know and bear with me
so two people could commit the same
crime or be uh sentenced the same amount
of time and one works their behind off
goes above and beyond and will get the
same we'll go to parole after you know
when they're eligible just as the other
person who may not do anything they
could lay in their bed for their entire
seven years and because they were not a
troublemaker these two people will get
paroled at the same time and that isn't
fair you know and if we're going to make
and again I'm using this analogy because
you know uh capitalism right that's
incentive based and so a change in um
you know giving folks an opportunity
Behind the Walls to get that incentive
to get out would be you know would be
huge so some guys that just you know
just discouraged as soon as they get in
and and never think to uh um to do more
than they have to some guys just barely
get by and these two two same people
could get out at the same
time um I'm going to wrap it up and you
know if anyone has any questions um more
more than welcome to uh receive
them thank you for your testimony
representative M you recognize for a
question just thank you for taking my
question and thank you for sharing your
story um I'm I'm wondering one of the
things we hear a lot about in these
cases is the the moment when someone in
your situation the the light goes on for
them you know they realize that that
they have to change and they really sort
of start the process of
changing how many years elapsed between
the time the light went on for you and
the time you were actually able to get a
hearer thank you for your question and I
think that's a great question you know
for me personally um I would say it
wasn't like a aha moment it was a
gradual change
[Music]
but I would say halfway through my
sentence is when I started you know
almost by fault getting involved in more
programs just to get out of the unit
just to break up the monotony um there
was one program in particular that
really you know I can I can kind of look
back at as that as the Catalyst for my
change and um you know again it was a
gradual thing you know it's breaking old
habits the same habits that you know L
me to
prison and um so I would say halfway the
halfway mark seven and a half years more
or less was when you know I was able to
um uh to start making that change and it
was gradual and you know it just kind of
was like a Snowball Effect and you know
I got more uh momentum behind me with
the more programs I did the more
education I got um and it was just you
know again it was it was it was for some
might be a single moment but for me I
would say that halfway point kind of was
like that hump I
reached I hope that helped answering
your question represent M you're
recognized for a follow off question yes
and thank you and and what was your
original sentence my original sentence
was uh 18 to 36 years and I was able to
get two years um suspended through the
65120 and I was able to get an
additional 10 months um through earn
time in if I could speak just about earn
time real quick 10 at that point when I
was eligible for it was the max you can
get without having to pay for College
college is the only other way at that
point that you can max out the 23 months
since I've been released I know that the
commissioner um and I believe the
legislator have been able to make some
changes and add some programs to that
but so my that ceiling may have may go
up but for the most part and able to get
the full benefit of the earn time credit
bill you need to pay for college and if
you don't have the funds then you're not
getting
that thank
you seeing no further hands raised I
want to thank the witness for his
testimony witness is
excused thank you now recognizes Nicole
pery hi my name is Nicole paresi I'm
from New York um I represent the New
Hampshire Department correction of
inmates I am a prison wife um I actually
do agree with this bill and I hope it
does pass um being from on the other
side from an outsider having a husband
that's in the Department of Corrections
um who's serving um 25 to life
sentence um but a crime that he did not
do um my question is to you guys I would
like to see if someone can answer for me
um when serving life without parole for
something that we're wrongfully
convicted of but also has so much
evidence that wasn't the person that
committed the crime but still got life
without parole that has to serve life
without parole for something that he
didn't do how does the family feel that
will not be able to have life with their
loved ones outside of prison if you
don't pass this bill I think everybody
deserves a second chance also in New
Hampshire Department of Corrections they
recently just took away their
educational
program now they're taking away a lot of
programs due to funding
also the covid As We Know has got out of
control everywhere in prison is even
worse they can't do anything they're
locked up you know they're on lockdown
when they love these programs these
programs give them hope that if they do
these programs they're going to have
early release um he just recently put in
his good earn time for just finishing a
program for educational and it wasn't
accepted and I don't think that's fair
especially when they need hope
especially when they're trying to get
out early and they're trying to make a
difference and I'm from New York and we
have the true sentencing law New
Hampshire is the only state doesn't have
it right now and I do as a prison wife I
really hope you guys do pass this bill
and not all inmates are dangerous
they're not all criminals they make
mistakes and they realize what they did
and they need to come back into this
world and start a new life thank
you
thank you for your testimony seeing No
Hands raised the witness is
excused chair now recognizes
representative Maria
Perez thank you for the opportunity uh
Mr chair for letting me speak um um
Colin uh to support HB 598 and HB
138 um I believe as a humans we're not
perfect and no one is perfect and people
have the right to have a second chance
and people who committed crimes and most
of the times a lot of times they're not
crimes that are they can you know they
should be convicted for life sentence I
believe people they should have the
opportunity to be involved with a
programs um they can teach them uh
different um maybe um we have so many so
many fields so many trades that they
need people to be trained we have so
many people in in a lot of Trades that
they they get and retired and then we
need people on the trades and then I
believe that a lot of these people they
can be trained in this these uh
different fields and they can get it
integrated to the society if they give
we give them the opportunity to be part
of our society um that's why I support
these two bills because I I truly
believe that are people Des serve and
they should have a second chance um to
be better for not just for the soul but
for for our communities and for the
society thank you
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
representative you
excuse thank
you this time the chair
recognizes Joseph
Eber
good morning members of the committee my
name is Joseph Ebert it's
EBT I am a captain with the New
Hampshire State Police I oversee our
Investigative Services Bureau um as
always I thank the committee very much
for the opportunity to speak to you this
morning um I'm uh speaking today on
House Bill
138 uh and uh although a great deal has
been uh discussed and I I won't
reiterate points that have already been
made uh there were a few things that I
thought be mentioned one of which is uh
the possibility that the passage of 138
may affect clean
negotiations um and having somebody
accept responsibility for the crime that
they have committed uh if somebody has
the ability to uh petition for parole
although uh it is clearly not guaranteed
that may very well uh weigh upon their
decision as to whether or not to take
resp responsibility um and enter into a
plea negotiation so I think that's an
ancillary or a an unintended uh perhaps
effect on the on the system that the
passage of 138 would
have um I also wanted to just point out
that uh people who re uh receive a life
sentence the I'm not aware of anybody
ple to a life sentence I'm going to say
that that has never happened but uh
people who receive a life sentence are
people who have chosen to go to trial
who have uh in most cases not accepted
responsibility for that crime uh either
because they uh they claim that they uh
did not commit it which is uh certainly
uh their right to do so uh but I wanted
to point out that the the individuals
who are sentenced to a life sentence had
a number of mechanisms with which to uh
to not end up in that situation um and
then as it
uh as uh representative scitec had
discussed uh the the purpose of that
parole hearing as I understand it is not
one to bring forward evident items of
evident value uh but there is an appeals
process that is in place for individuals
uh who receive a conviction uh and
lastly I I would just say that um having
worked for over a decade in uh the major
crime unit which is primarily the
homicide investigation unit for the
State of New Hampshire I see the
terrible effects that
homicides have on everyone involved um
and as was mentioned before by a
previous speaker the retraumatization of
individuals uh family members who have
to continually go back uh whether it be
for a parole hearing or uh it be for an
appeal hearing is tremendous um that's
my observation I don't speak on their
behalf because um thankfully I've never
been in that position but my observation
has been is is incred ibly traumatic for
those individuals to go back through
that process so having said that I I am
of course willing to take any questions
that the committee members may
have representative Newman you recognize
for a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you to the witness for his testimony and
taking my question I may have misheard
you or may I may have misunderstood you
but I I want to be absolutely sure you
talked about knowing ever ping to a deal
or down ping whatever they call it um
that you didn't know of one um are are
you making any kind of connection
between a person's um right not to take
a plea if they're innocent even though
it puts him in much greater Jeopardy for
a much greater
penalty no I first of all thank you for
the question and uh and again I I want
to make sure I I I try hard never to
make a a true true hard fast statement
um of fact because there is there are
always occasions when uh somebody may
enter into a plea agreement for a life
sentence um to avoid a uh a death
penalty case something like that there's
a it's a very rare circumstance but uh
having said that representative Newman
what is so important to emphasize is I
never want to penal penalize somebody
and nor does the uh the division of
State Police ever want to penalize
somebody for exercising their rights
or uh for penalize somebody who is
innocent of a crime what I what I was
saying or what I was trying to convey
and I probably didn't do in as clear a
fashion as I I could have is uh that an
individual who receives a life sentence
has been adjudicated through the system
they have been found guilty they have
had their opportunity to argue uh their
facts and circumstances and a judge or
Jury has found them uh guilty of that
charge what I'm saying is that that
individual
uh had the knowledge of what really
happened and they chose not to enter
into that plea agreement and they may uh
be more likely to not enter into a plea
agreement and accept responsibility for
a crime they committed not that they did
not commit for a crime that they
committed they may be less likely to
enter into a plea agreement to accept
responsibility for the a crime they
committed if they know that there is a
built-in safety valve of of the
possibility of Cor in 25 years so I I
hope that clears it up but I want to
make that crystal clear that I never
want somebody to engage in any type of
plea uh agreement or ple conversation if
they're innocent of a
crime thank you very much for that
Crystal Clear
clarification seeing No Hands raised I
want to thank the witness for his
testimony the witness is excused thank
you the chair now recognizes John
[Music]
no you
didn't hello am I on no you're not
kri you
recognized all right try now yes uh
thank you very much I'm sorry U uh I had
problems with the mute button um to the
representatives thank you for taking the
time to uh to listen to my suppor of
House Bill
598 um I am a criminal defense attorney
in Massachusetts I've been a criminal
defense attorney for some 35 years um
I've seen uh many people come back from
prison rehabilitated and enter into the
system um I am concerned uh with New
Hampshire uh uh programs being cut for
the inmates um and them not being able
to obtain credits uh towards their
release um I think that um
uh truth and sentencing has been uh
around for too long at this point and I
believe that um uh that the inmates uh
can U engage in programs that can help
themselves and I think they need that
knowledge that if they uh work on
Rehabilitation that in fact somewhere
down the line um that they have the
opportunity to be released early thank
you very much um and if there's any
questions I'm willing to take
them
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
thank the witness for his testimony
thank
you the chair now recognizes Jennifer
sergeant and for any members of the
public who are in attendance who wish to
testify that have not testified already
please raise your
hand can you hear me didn't
comment okay thank you very much my name
is Jennifer sergeant and I very much
appreciate the committee's taking the
time this morning to uh allow me to
participate I am the chairman of the New
Hampshire Adult Parole Board I have um
asked Donna scitec to speak on the
parole board's behalf she did a
wonderful job there are a couple of
things that I would like to
clarify uh if I may um the first is
regarding incentive versus Community
safety
incentive as we've heard for residents
in the Department of Corrections prison
very important
wholeheartedly uh agree that there
should be incentives and there should be
programs Community
safety is the most important thing that
concerns the parole board we have very
specific criteria which we must apply
why in order to decide if a resident has
met the criteria for
parole we consider that criteria against
What the residents have done what
programs they've engaged in but also
their conduct in the prison also their
um support systems outside their housing
plan their ability to be supervised all
of the things um besides programming are
definitely taken into consideration and
it's not just one type of programming or
another that we look at I do want to
specifically speak to Medical parole
medical parole is dictated by Statute
and we also have administrative rules
that further require us to uh evaluate
petitions for medical parole they are
few and far between however they do
happen and I'm speaking in opposition of
House Bill
598 because there are many mechanisms
and I'm not going to repeat what Donna
saitech said there are many mechanisms
including medical parole if necessary in
order to allow for a resident who it has
certain needs um to be released I want
to talk to the practicality of HB 59 98
before the
board we have found on the parole board
and we know that
unless residents do
programming and they do it at first and
significantly with the
structure that the doc inside the prison
provides that gives them the
foundational tools to then go outside to
do more treatment more programming and
to be
compliant the fear is
that if 598 were to be in effect and if
residents could go before the parole
board at half of their minimum that they
would not have had adequate time given
when the Department of Corrections
engages them in the programming because
the Department of Corrections does look
at their minimum sentences as a trigger
for timing in which to enroll them in
certain
Correctional uh programming such as the
focus program if they come before the
parole board the residents if they come
before the parole board at half of their
minimum what is going to be the problem
is that they programming and their
development is often not going to be
sufficient enough for us to find them
Parable under the criteria that is in
the administrative rules what I'm saying
is that they will not be sufficiently
through all of the things that they need
to develop so that parole will be able
to find that they are going to be
paroled under our very specific criteria
in our administrative rules what I'm
afraid that this will do is create a
false hope for residents who will be
seeking parole and will have a parole
hearing everybody every resident if this
bill passes will be automatically put
onto the parole list and it will be
noticed publicly as we are required to
do by law the parole board will not not
have the option of saying No this person
isn't ready yet for a hearing or yes
this person isn't ready for a hearing
yet that's not how it works what our
office does is look at where they are
timing wise in relation to their parole
eligibility date which is their minimum
um which would be half of their minimum
if 598 passes and they automatically get
scheduled for a parole hearing this
would significantly increase the number
if it is in fact applied to Residents
who are already in the prison it would
significantly increase the number of
hearings that would have to
happen um I'm worried about the fact
that we would be seeing people uh seeing
residents too early and they would not
have fulfilled um the obligations for
them to meet the criteria for
parole additionally Donna sitech has
spoken about the effect on victims uh it
would create a situation where I'm
afraid more often than not victims would
have to prepare for these hearings and
these hearings would more often than not
not result in parole because the
residents would not have been able to
complete enough programming um and have
have had structure for long
enough uh to make themselves um adequate
risks um regarding Community safety
moreover
uh the staff
involved um and the parole board budget
is very limited at this time hb2 that we
have also proposed and there's been
discussion about briefly today is the
first step in making the parole office
able to handle a lot more um a lot more
work adding staff um building up our
potential to hear more residents on a
more frequent basis the parole board
ideally would love to be full-time
that's not going to happen yet but we
believe in seeing as many residents as
possible as often as possible that is
the goal right now the Staffing and the
uh resources are not adequate to
overload our office with a number with
the number of Perle hearings that I fear
will happen if 598 passes as a result we
will not have the ability to amass
adequate information about all of the
residents it's very difficult for our
staff to gather um a sign significant
amount of information from all different
uh sources and places in order to
prepare the parole packets that the
parole uh members
use we want to make sure that we're
making decisions for the residents and
for the community based on the
most uh and the best information that we
can get about all of the residents um
and all of their plans and their
accomplishments we are Pro relase that
is evident from the fact that we work
hard to uh get as much information as we
can and work very closely with the do so
that we can release people to the
community safely but 598 is potentially
going to create an onslaught that need
not happen given the opportunities for
earn time credit that are available
given the opportunities for medical
parole that are available and also um
because of the inadequacies that we have
currently with staff and office size um
we hope to with hb2 get a start on
trying to hear
more uh more residents more frequently
but right now what is asked in
598 um is diff difficult to accomplish
practically on the ground for our board
and I uh thank you for hearing me I will
take any questions that you may
have chairman thank you to the witness
for taking the question and for the nice
presentation several times today I've
heard from different Witnesses the
discussion around
programs uh for inmates and how
completion of these programs is um a
requisite for being considered a likely
candidate for parole can you offer some
clarity on uh the timing that these
programs would occur and could these
programs begin sooner to then allow the
inmate to complete them sooner um
and I guess that would be a good start
would you mind doing that um I will to
the extent that I can and the answer to
your question is I can't tell you when
program certain programs are allowed to
start as that is the purview of the
Department of Corrections the
programming is run entirely by the
Department of Corrections and the
Department of Corrections is the
organization the body the agency that
allows and um enrolls the residents in a
variety of the programming that we do
require such as um the focus program
mental health treatment sex offender
treatment uh it is really um the timing
of the programming is set by the
Department of Corrections for those
canical programs on the other hand there
are residents who can Avail themselves
of programs on what we call the tablet a
GTL system that allows them to complete
programs that we look favorably upon um
and it's my understanding those are free
and those are available to any Resident
with access to a tablet and tablets are
readily available so those types of
programs residents can be um working on
available on the tablet right now there
is no
Standalone um drug
rehabilitation um type program that is
used without being used in conjunction
with a group type program a
therapeutically based program um the
focus program is the therapeutically
based program and that has has
traditionally and continues to be um a
program that is monitored and requires
um input and uh design with the
behavioral health staff um Additionally
the sex offender treatment program is
similar um in that it it is not a
standalone program that be can be done
on a tablet or as a selflearning unit um
and that is also true at this point for
anger man management although I have
spoken with the commissioner and will
represent that she is trying very hard
to add a variety of treatment um
oriented programs to the tablet as
self-learning units it's uh but but to
answer your question the timing for
programming is out of parole board's
hands um it is uh up to the Department
of Corrections to gauge when and if it
allows an uh a resident into um a
particular
program thank you chairman thank you
Miss Sergeant I thank you for taking my
question I do have to say um listening
to you in to Donna I learned a lot that
I just simply I guess I I never even
thought that I needed to know these
things um but something specific I want
to ask that I think that you'd be the
best person from all the people that
testified so when we have an inmate that
is transferred out of
state is does that inmate Still Still
follow the New
Hampshire like the New Hampshire
laws as far as you know what has to be
met or would it follow that particular
State when we have an inmate who is
transferred out of state they do still
have to abide by the programming that
the parole board requires so for
instance if someone in the New Hampshire
if an inmate in the New Hampshire system
has been recommended or required to do
sex offender treatment and then is
transferred out of state the New
Hampshire Department of Corrections
through um the sex offender program um
and the professionals who work in that
program they're usually the ones who
will coordinate with that outof state
facility to make sure that the
programming that they're a able to do
out of state meets the criteria of the
programming that would be offered in New
Hampshire if that inmate had remained in
New
Hampshire
um if the programming in the other state
is insufficient oftentimes what will
happen is that the uh inmate will be
brought back to the New Hampshire State
Prison in order to complete the
programming that would be required by
the Professionals in New Hampshire does
that answer your question
I believe so thank
you representative M you have a
question you thank you Mr chairman um I
I'm just curious if you think that the
amount of time served on the part of of
an inmate um should be dependent on
things that that seem to be outside of
the inmates control and and by by that I
mean it seems like uh programs uh appear
they disappear
um
expectations uh can change um and it it
seems like there's a lot of potential uh
for people to fall into the cracks and
even to run into a uh you know various
catch22 situations in the system just
wondering if you could comment on
that well if I understand your question
correctly I think what you're asking me
is a question question about
fairness is that fair to say like
whether it
is whether it is a good policy or a h a
good practice to not
consider inmates for parole until they
have completed certain programming where
their ability to get into that
programming um may be caused by a delay
that is not their own I think that's
another way of saying it okay um I'm not
going to
answer regarding whether it's fair
because it we are bound to consider
parole eligibility by
criteria and we also H have to always
consider Public Safety as part of that
criteria as a major part of that
criteria
so the bottom line
becomes whether we believe it's fair or
not how long it takes a resident to get
into a type of
programming we ultimately are not going
to make a decision to parole
someone if we don't believe that they
are not safe in the community and that
they are not invested and able to
maintain their re-entry
um followup and after care
treatment they have to be prepped and
ready in the prison to go out into the
community where there is less
structure in order to carry on with all
of the things that the programming in
the prison enables them to gain
foundationally if they cannot get those
things in the prison then they are not
safe to be often I'm not saying in every
case but they are often just not safe to
be in the community that is absolutely
why programming in the prison is
essential and frankly and I'm speaking
for myself
now this shouldn't programming in the
prison should not be cut it should be
encouraged um and the commissioner is
dedicated to trying to get more
programming in um there are issues in
the Department of Corrections uh that
I'm not aware of because I I don't work
for them what I can tell you is when it
comes to paroling someone we have to
look at whether or not they meet the
criteria and whether they've been
prepared entered into programming
and engaged in self betterment to the
extent that they are safe in the
community and that they meet the
criteria for peole does that make sense
if not I'll I'll try again
yes thank you
okay you have a further
[Music]
question thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you for taking my
question um could you give me some or
the committee some idea of how often you
run into a
prisoner who has met all of the
criteria except the programs that are
required but runs into his minimum
sentence time uh and the only thing that
is preventing that prisoner from being
considered for parole is that the
required programs have not been
completed I don't have a definite number
for you I can tell you that um because
the focus program is about about six
months long sex offender treatment can
take and it can take more or less time
um based on the part the the active
participation of the resident and and
the investment that the resident makes
um sex offender treatment the same um
other programming the same um many times
what happens is if a an inmate is
enrolled already in the programming and
their hearing is coming up they will do
one of two things either they will
postpone their hearing until they are
close to finishing the program or have
finished the program because they know
that's if they're enrolled the the
parole board is going to require them to
complete it um or they will appear
before parole and they will ask for a
conditional parole par parole me upon
the completion of my program um and
sometimes the parole board will do that
and sometimes it won't but but um we
have we've we've done that often um in
the year that I have been on the board
what we have noticed and this is a
product of um I believe in in good part
covid but I I cannot speak for the
Department of Corrections is we have
noticed that uh the focus program as J
Macky mentioned has a very long waiting
list um we are currently residents are
being brought up to the North Country
facility to be doing that as it is not
currently running at the conquered
facility um but there is a waiting list
most uh residents who are coming in are
triggering in their initial intake for
substance use disorder treatment and
that requires them to go through
substance use disorder treatment um
there is no Standalone learning unit to
go through substance use disorder
treatment nor am I convinced um and this
is my unprofessional opinion that there
is a uh an a learning tablet learning
unit which substitutes for Asam criteria
um addiction uh criteria that would be
adequate for treatment so do we do we
see people in who would be eligible at
their minimum who have not who have been
on the focus list or other treatment
lists who have not enrolled yes we've
seen an increase that in the last year
but that may be because of limited
movement in the prison uh due to covid
it may be um
protections uh it may be availability of
beds that is something that I would
suggest the commissioner um speak to and
not myself but yes we we have people on
the waiting list that we will not parole
because they have not yet been able to
engage in meaningful
treatment
Mr chairman yes you may thank you very
much um you mentioned tablets and
tablets are readily available yes are
those tablets available from uh the
government and are they free or do they
have to have someone buy them those
tablets I don't know the answer to that
that is a Department of
Corrections purchase and
distribution thank you very
much
further questions from the
committee no hands up thank we thank the
witness for a testimony Mr chairman
thank you very
much sorry oh there was one with a hand
up but I let me but it's gone Mr
chairman um so if there is anybody that
is out there that wants to speak please
raise your
hand Mr chairman I'm not seeing
anybody let me double check yep no I'm
on the right
screen no no I don't see anybody Mr
chairman oh then I guess we will close
the public hearing on House Bill
138 Mr chairman yeah thank you Mr
chairman on House Bill
598 we had 72 people signing in in
support uh and we had five people
signing in an
opposition on House Bill
138 we had 30 people signing in in
support and four people signing in in
opposition
is
Clos I guess we will be in recess
72 um Mr chairman I think I overheard
that we were going to go into recess at
12:15 um let me go get the chairman the
other chairman if we if I may we're a
little early we are that's why I'm
thinking you know I don't know what he
had up his sleeves but I think it was
something
check with I'll be right
back see he's
buying
why
would
not see him out
there we to the
S 1:00 yes at 1:00 all right the
committee will be in recess until
1:00 party
oh
for
e
okay mics are on look at me look at me
nobody reminds me to put
my
hamsters
s
that I saw come
down last night so then she says send it
again so I sent it to her again we're
cool
I have it in my email I'm just saying
the cop as long as everyone's cool it
not I think this one we don't
need and was there another
one for 205 or
something
[Music]
ien I don't
know
get good
[Music]
but I don't see
it but I heard that he sent shapar sent
it out which he shouldn't he should have
sent it to Karen and this is how we get
screwed up with
Amendment yeah um can you take care of
the
camera can you ask Karen J Do It
Amendment for 205 yes okay oh
yeah secret
me is that good now Mr chair
yes Laura hear
us oh she can
okay I'm probably going to start in
about two minutes so I'm just wondering
is that a shotgun behind her
chair oh she can't hear
me the members at home hear us please
thumbs up thumbs
down
oh yes you
can represent Bo get the most calls
yes oh there she is how are you doing
Laura great thank you
you you still got that heavy purse that
I'm scared of yes and I'm bringing it in
John I can't believe that you and I have
voted so many times together I I know
people are gonna start talking about us
right
wrong
[Music]
yeah it's good when we
can that's
right
Evan on the
next all the down correct for the
members at home to give you a heads up
we're going to open with an executive
session on 18 435
[Applause]
yes
representative har Gard I did send that
message off to
Karen she's usually
[Music]
prettying we don't
need
[Music]
I keep
all I thought from over there oh we have
the one I no this 430
chairman yes representative pel office
our
hand afternoon represent get a hand
raised yes I thought we were stting a
hearing on
205 we are we do have uh
130 we have five minutes in we're going
to try to make best use of our time to
get through what I hope hope to be a
simple housekeeping
me thank
you good afternoon at this
time we going to reopen the executive
session on House Bill 4
represent consideration yes I'd like to
thank you Mr chairman um I'd like to
make a motion to reconsider House Bill
436 is there a second to that motion
second that motion is second by
representative
Welsh speak motion uh just briefly um um
I think I'll let representative uh jth W
do most of the speaking on this
amendment because she's the one that put
it fourth but it it eliminated any
concerns that I had of the bill by
removing the date so I'm I'm okay with
the bill and I'll be voting in favor of
it thank you m see no hands
raised matter we put the
question
up all if you in favor the motion of
reconsideration please say yay if you
opposed please say
N I would ask the members at home please
turn the C on to the durations
vote representative B yes representative
Hopper yes representative
green
representative Wallace
I representative testerman yes
representative true yay representative
crab yes representative jet
yes V yes representative Harry G
yes representative
Tas yes
represent
yes representative of Hearn
yes representative Bon
yes representative Muse
yes representative Newman
yes representative
Balden yes representative Conley yes
representative Klein Knight yes
representative Bradley yes chairman the
chair votes yes Mr chairman the vote is
Z Thank You by a vote of 20 y Zer n the
motion for reconsideration has
passed this time the chair recognize
representative Gaff for a motion to pass
it
amend I move to a to pass as
amended and just to clarify that amend 2
21- 057
sorry it's 0587
h is there a second I'll second it Mr
chairman that motion is second by
representative gther you wish to speak
to your motion no I think
we seeing No Hands rate representative
Hearn you recognize just for
clarification if ation again goes
towards procedure we have to first
accept the amendment and vote on it and
then AR to pass with the amendment yes
this is a motion to the motion is off to
pass you have to have a positive motion
on the full which we now have at that
point represent gather is Al also
offered an amendment so we are now
voting on the amendment on to adopt the
amendment seeing No Hands raised uh
matter would you put the question
the clerk Now call a rooll if you in
favor of adopting Amendment 202-
0587 please say yay if you were opposed
please say
next Vice chairman wels
hi representative B yes representative
Hopper
yes representative
green representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative TR yay
representative Pratt yes representative
duet
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Harry GA yes representative
panus yes representative o' yes
representative bord
yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Balden
yes representative Conley yes
representative clein Knight yes
representative Bradley yes chairman the
chair votes yes the vote is
20 zero I voted 20 y 20 Nays the the
amendment
passes C housekeep want to make a motion
again as off pass as amended yes I make
the motion that HB 436 ought to pass as
amended second that motion is second by
representative
Welsh Mr speak any
motion I see no hands raised uh the
matter we put the question the cler I
all the RO if you in favor of to pass as
amended please say yay if you opposed
please say
nay
chairman wel hi representative B yes
representative copper yes representative
green representative Wallace yes
representative testman y representative
true
May representative PR
yes representa you yes votes yes
represent representative har G yes
representative
pakus yes representative o'
yes representative B
yes representative mes
yes representative Newman yes
representative
bden yes representative Conley yes
representative clein Knight yes
representa Bradley yes chairman the
chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 19 yay one
nay vot 19 Y and one nay the motion of a
the pass as
amended has passed a move for
consent representative
Newman I withraw the I just want to ask
a question go ahead and do what we're
doing I don't have a
question this time we will close the
executive session on house bille 438
repr together will you be preparing the
majority report
yes this time we are opening the public
hearing for House Bill 205 relative to
incarceration under a suspended
sentence this time the chair recognizes
representative
introd can you hear me yes we can hear
you representative thank you m good
afternoon Mr chairman and honorable
members of the criminal justice and
Public Safety Committee for the record I
am representative Joe Shapiro chesher 16
city of Keem
I come before you today to introduce
House Bill 205 a bill relative to
incarceration under a suspended sentence
this bill is identical to last year's
HB 1611 although I will be proposing a
minor Amendment which you should have
already received via
email last year's HB 1611 was voted
ought to pass in this committee by a
vote of 20 to zero and passed in the
house by a Voice vote
unfortunately it was one of the many
bills that were placed on the table in
the Senate due to
covid-19 hb25 makes a small but
important fix to a statute that allows
residents serving as a sentence in state
prison to petition for suspension of
their sentence after serving two-thirds
of their time the amount of time served
does not change what does change is that
instead of waiting to reach the 2third
mark to be able to petition residents
will now be able to petition earlier
giving them the needed time to receive a
court date wait for that court date and
to enter and hopefully complete any
needed rehabilitative programming
related to their
eligibility currently residents must
wait till they have served two-thirds of
their sentence to petition and if it is
eventually approved their release would
occur well after the 23ds time you will
see that the bill is introduced calls
for an 18-month time frame and the
amendment
reduces and the amendment reduces that
time frame to 12 months to address
concerns from the Department of
Corrections I believe that commissioner
Hanks or representative from the
department will be testifying in support
of that shorter time
frame I want to take just a moment to
give credit for this bill to the RCC the
resident Communications committee a
group of residents at the conquered
prison for men whom I met with some two
years ago these men many serving very
long sentences work with their fellow
inmates to support a positive adjustment
to prison life and work with corrections
administrators to advocate for
constructive policy changes it was this
very impressive group of men that
identified this frustrating glitch and
offered what I believe is a very helpful
and very reasonable
fix thank you and I would be glad to
take any questions
thank you representative seeing No Hands
raised your
excuse members of the public who wish to
testify that are currently in attendance
please raise your hands at this time uh
as a discretion of the chair we can
limit testimony on house 205 to one
minute
I
recogniz
may good afternoon I would like to thank
the chairman as well as the committee
for allowing me to speak uh my name is
Josiah Mayo I'm a lifelong resident of
New Hampshire and constituent uh I am
supportive he Bill
205 I believe passing this bill gives
residents an opportunity to prepare for
their eventual release this is not a Go
Home free passed as we know a judge
still has to make a decision and the
parole board still has to Grant parole
uh we we have heard testimony today that
states programming is contingent upon a
resident minimum parole date part of
parole release criteria is based upon
residents completing programming um I
would like to clarify what that means an
18-year-old resident who has been sent a
three and a half years sentence would be
forced to coexist with other residents
who have been neglected or further
criminalized due to the lack of timely
programming and we reabilitation uh in
one of the most extreme and deprived
environments um this bill in fact helps
residents if eligible to access
programming sooner which I believe is
Paramount to Rehabilitation successful
reentry as well as Public Safety um I
support this bill for those reasons that
I have stated um my hope is that this
committee does as well take any
questions you may have thank
you thank you for your testimony seeing
No Hands raised the witness is
exed now recognizes J
Mackey Mr reminder your testimony is is
limited to one minute Mr chairman was
that Matthew or
Mackie J ma thank you Mr
chairman good afternoon chairman can
everyone hear me yes great um thank you
for allowing me to testify on this bill
um my name is Jay Mackey I'm the
administrator of classifications and
client records for the New Hampshire
Department Corrections as we are
originally were opposed to this bill
with the 18-month time frame the
12-month amendment is a a more suitable
time frame that we have seen and we do
support that Amendment um as discussed
earlier today with the house bill 598
some of the issues arising is about
getting into programs in a in a in a
proper time frame so when we do Supply
the court with all the needed
information we um sometimes they do not
have the ability to get into the
programs because based on their minimum
parole date they were never able to get
into the programs because getting their
two-thirds is not something that is
always granted so we can't rely on that
to get them into those programs we
usually get them into those programs
around two years to their minimum um so
that was an issue that was raised but
with the 12month time frame we do
support this bill and I can take any
questions
thank you for your testimony
representative TR you recognize for our
question thank you Mr chair uh and thank
you for taking my question
um in your opinion what what makes the
12 month acceptable to you but the 18
month
not month so this bill produces allows
someone that is sentenced to a six-year
minimum their two-thirds would be after
four years 18 18 months is about two and
a half years when they can apply they've
only served two and a half years of a
six-year minimum there's not really
enough body of work that we would be
able to supply for the court for them to
make a good decision on whether or not
this person should be granted two thirds
it also an issue that arises is if that
person is granted their two-thirds
around 18 months to their minimum what
is the what happens when they start uh
if they start committing major
disciplinary violations at the prison
most likely that falls on us to contact
the County Attorney um to see if they
would like the motion to impose the
suspended portion of the sentence um we
just say 18 months is too much of a time
frame where they don't have enough
programming to be completed that would
allow them to be eligible for parole and
even if the court does grant their
two-thirds they may not be able to be
released on parole because they have not
completed that programming as it
is um did I answer your question yes
thank you
seeing no further hands raised the
witness is
excused I recognize
Joseph thank you chair and members of
this
committee um my name is Joseph laskas I
will be representing the ACLU of New
Hampshire and myself in full support of
this legislation uh HP 205 and I hope
that this committee votes ought to pass
on it as well
um I myself have utilized the suspended
sentence um system uh when I was
incarcerated uh I I've gone through it
um and a successful re-entry after
incarceration requires preparation um
hands down a critical step in advancing
Public Safety is reducing recidivism by
making sure that people successfully
re-enter into their communities after
incarceration and re-entry posts a host
of challenges for incarcerated
individuals particularly for people who
have been in prison for years years or
even decades such as like you know
culture shock uh identifying housing and
employment state identification needs
that need to be renewed um just to name
a few of the
challenges so it it boils down to that a
successful re-entry that requires um
time and HB 205 doesn't lessen
accountability instead it promotes
responsibility it incentivizes the
decision to make a commitment to a
positive lifestyle change and re-entry
and it happens by promoting
responsibility by causing residents to
start to develop the necessary
forethought and judgment skills to
manage their own life and plan for their
future as well as incentivizing them to
commit to making a lifestyle change
because just because you are granted a
suspended sentence until you reach your
parole date that privilege could be
withdrawn at the request of the
doc your your time has expired so I do
have to ask you to conclude your
test uh this bill doesn't this bill
doesn't guarantee that anyone's going to
go home all it does is allow people to
prepare for an eventuality which is what
we're looking for in successful
reent thank you again for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness is
excused just sign the chair recognizes
Donna
Brown a reminder testimony be limited to
one minute thank you um this is attorney
Donna Brown I am representing the New
Hampshire Association criminal defense
lawyers and I won't repeat um I agree we
we are in favor of this bill and I agree
with everything that's been said before
as a lawyer who regularly does these
bills uh I mean does these motions I I
just wanted to add a couple of things
that also add on to the time I I agree
uh in in terms of getting people into
programming um once you file this motion
and some very times I've filed it the
day it's been allowed so we tried to get
them filed as soon as possible then the
other has 30 days to respond so now
everything comes to a grinding halt for
the response and then there's something
called a synopsis that the Department of
Corrections wres which is basically a
summary of the inmate that goes to the
judge that takes time too and it can't
be done ahead of time so there's these
things like the reply from the
prosecution and the synopsis that hold
things up so it's not you just file the
motion and then the judge decides many
times it can take four or five months
after someone's eligible before they um
actually get their day in court or get a
ruling and I'll limit my uh testimony at
that
point thank you again for your testimony
seeing No Hands raised the witness is
excused chair now
recognizes EV EV
P thank you chair um my name is evanor
Panetta I'm in support of I'm sorry I
keep forgetting the bills names uh
numbers but I'm in support of this
bill um I also was formerly incarcerated
I'm I am a a resident of Nashville New
Hampshire um I'm representing
myself um HB 205 I'm suppor of HB 205 I
I personally went through the um prison
system I also had files for uh 65120 to
amend my
sentence and I fully understand that you
know no one is ever able to fully uh
realized the full power of this bill of
65120 because you're not eligible until
you've reached two-thirds of your
sentence so right off the rip you're
you're you're you're not able
to fully enjoy that if you're granted
that by the court I'm
sorry so I'm full of support giving a
year out gives plenty of time and
preparation I
personally it took me a year before I
actually filed past my two3 point um
because I was trying to get all my ducks
in a row and I was also trying to go
through the dolc to get uh the the um uh
a letter recommendation from from the
commissioner commissioner run at that
time and uh I was successful at least as
I'm getting some time a portion of that
uh time granted me two years but again I
just want to say that uh support it I
know time is limited um and it would be
beneficial to the inmates and to the
staff on the inside to get the process
going it's a it is a long drawn up
process thank
you thank you thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the wi
is
excused if there's any members of the
public who wish to testify that have not
testified already please raise your
hand
seeing no additional hands
raised Mr yes Don Brown I believe Donna
Brown's already testified oh I'm sorry
thank you Mr chairman is that the same
Donna Brown from
before I did not recognize the
name Mr chairman my apologies that she
diding seeing no additional hands raised
at this time we'll close the include the
public public hearing on House Bill
205 and the signin on House Bill 205 we
had 63 people sign in in support and
five people sign in in
opposition thank you
representative at this time we're going
to reopen the executive session on H
Bill 238
recognize yes Mr chairman I would like
to be recognized to reconsider House
Bill
238 true
second that motion for reconsideration
has been
seconded wish to speak to your
motion
no before we put that question forward
just address a few a few
issues move this along quickly first any
member wishes to object to any ruling of
the chair of
procedure is it's appropriate for that
me to raise a point of order especially
if there's any question on whether the
parliamentary procedures being
follow
now it is difficult when multiple
members once whether they're in the room
or participating remotely especially
what makes it difficult is
multiple voices are coming through the
same microphone or speaker at the same
time so and it was apparently a point of
order was raised by a member in this
room that I could not even hear that's
how loud it was so I would ask
that if there is any questions of the
rules that we try to conduct ourselves
in Accords with the Parliamentary rules
simply if a rul is not being followed
does not mean we violate or fail to
follow additional rules now when it
matters is put the question the question
is put
forward we that means we are now in the
voting mod if a member's not in their
seat at the time the question is
put that member is not allowed to then
take their seat if they're not already
in the rule also prevents that member
from leaving the seat while we're in the
voting so I understand that if your
video cameras are on or
off uh if you're off I have no idea if
someone missing but if the camera's on I
see the chair or if the person's
physically present in the room and when
the question is put if you're not in
your chair in this room you are now not
allowed to take take your seat and
that's house Ru 107 if anyone is
interested in referring
to
so in respect to the the motion to
pertain when there was a number not in
their seat it was it was my
understanding of ruling because that
member was not in their seat when the
question was put that member would not
be permitted to take their
seat so when the role was called it
apparently that member's name was not
called which it should have been called
so for a housekeeping matter to make
sure we're doing our best we can to
follow follow the Parliamentary best we
can we're gonna I hope that this
reconsideration is allowed so we can
revote on on the
question I would just ask going forward
if there is any questions of the chair
that we try to do our best
to keep it calm because I think there a
lot of things were missed during the day
with that being
said I would like to put the question uh
move the
questions seeing No Hands
raised the M put the question up all the
RO if you in favor of the motion for
reconsideration please say yay if you
oppose please
in
I Vice chairman Welch hi representative
Bert yes representative Hopper yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative TR yay representative
Pratt yes
representative jet yes the clerk votes
yes representative Harry Gaff yes
representative pan loas yes
representative o'n yes representative B
yes representative Muse yes
representative Newman yes representative
Balden
yes representative Conley yes
representative K Knight yes
representative Broadley yes chairman the
chair votes yes Mr chairman the vote is
21 by a vote of 21 n z n the motion for
reconsideration pass this time the chair
is recognizing representative wels to
make a
motion I move that we
uh retain household
238 represent wall
second the motion to as been
seconded seeing No Hands raised the
matter put the question CL Now call the
RO you in favor to
retain we're in the voting
mode you in favor of the motion retain
please say yay if you are opposed please
say
n Vice chairman wels hi representative
Bert yes representative Hopper yep
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yeah representative
Pratt
yes representative jet yes the clerk
votes yes representative Harry G no
representative pus no representative Oar
no representative B no representative
muse
no representative Newman no
Representative bden no representative
Conley
no
represent
no representative Bradley
no chairman abis chair votes
yes
is 11 to 10 by a vote of 11 Y and 10 n
the motion to retain is
allowed this time we close the executive
session of house
238 represent you recognize yes uh will
we have a work s on that
bill uh we
can to tell you when that will happen I
I couldn't even
guess but I think that
that would be help of the committee I
just I I think that if you're G to
retain a bill that you would intend to
hold hearings on it in the
farm oh of course I just want to say
this I'm not sure what the summer time
bring as well as the fall I don't want
so I don't want to make any
representations that will confuse the
members all the
public thank
you
hopefully times
returns this time we are going to open
the executive
session on House Bill 138 allowing
prison serving a life sentence to the
elig RO for 25
[Music]
years
represent
Mr chairman I make a motion
to
itl is there a second second
second Yes actually
um we heard a lot of testimony today
obviously um what I'm hearing a lot of
is the person that is that is in jail
and or medical expenses um and it's it
actually very sad to me that we're
hearing everybody talking about that
nobody talking
about the victim or the family of the
reason why the person is in prison and I
think that that should be taken way more
into consideration than it was
personally and I I don't I think it's
yeah thank you represent
Rose the matter now be open up for
discussion represent con thank you Mr
chairman um co-sponsor of this
bill uh well first I'll say I'm going to
be leaving as soon as I finish speaking
I have an important work
call
problematic I support the concept of
this despite struggling with the impact
on victims and fact that people do Very
Bad Things um some people who do very
bad things should never be let out
of uh that said testimony today uh from
a number of people made me question my
decision to co-sponsor this B so if I'm
present in the room I will be voting for
it representative Bo you recognized
thank you Mr chair um I will not be
voting for itl I think that this is a
good bill um in 25 years uh people have
opportunity to rethink of what about
what they've done to mature uh we know
that the aging process uh changes uh uh
people's hormone levels and I think that
after 25 years uh if a person is still
uh behaving well
then they should have an opportunity to
have a pero Paro uh
review thank
you thank you represent
Bo representative
Newman thank you Mr chair
taking
uh thank you Mr chairman um I also will
be voting for this bill because I I also
believe that after 25 years and based on
the testimony we heard from the parole
people today that they take into
consideration uh the uh possibility of
the dangerousness of the person and how
they've reacted over those 25 years and
I think that if it's one of those people
that has not rehabilitated at all and is
truly a dangerous person they won't get
paroled but I think there's a
significant number of prisoners that may
have rehabilitated as as a matter of
fact I got a letter from one of them
that where there were multiple uh
degrees that were earned and multiple
ways that they had helped um other
prisoners to be
rehabilitated and I think that they
should at least have the the
um ability to have a hearing out of Paro
so I'll be voting for this Bill thank
you thank you
represent representative
Balden thank you Mr chairman um I'm
going to be opposing the itl as well um
I know that the state constitution
dictates that punishments should be
designed to reform and not to punish um
and I believe that if we have any
confidence in our prison system at all
we should have confidence that it's
possible for anyone to be reformed uh
during their stay so for that reason I'm
going to oppose the itl thank
you
representative Hopper thank you Mr chair
um I think institution was written there
were certain crimes that people did
where they executed them after they did
the crimes after their trial so there
was no need they were not reformable
because they were
dead would you believe that
no
seeing no further hands
raised matter will be put the question
the clerk will now call the role if you
in favor of the motion of in to
legislate please say yes if you are
opposed please say
no chairman Welch hi representative Bert
yes representative Hopper yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt yes representative jet yes the
clerk votes yes representative Harry
gffr no Representative pantelakis no
representative
o'n
yes
representative Gord
no representative muse
no representative
Newman you're
[Music]
muted represent
Newman
no just
Representative
bden
no representative
Conley representative Klein Knight
no representative Bradley no chairman
abis the chair votes
yes Mr chairman the vote is 12
to8 12
y i v 12 Y and eight
Mays the motion inexpedient to regate
has
passed at this time we will close the
executive session on o Bill
138 at this time we opening the public
on House Bill 443 relative to an
extended term of imprisonment for
assaulting military
[Music]
personnel
recognizing representative Edward Le to
introduce House Bill
443 uh thank you uh Mr chairman um this
is representative Edwards I'm I'm not
here to introduce the Bill I'm here to
testify on it I maybe the bill sponsor
is here my
representa that's all
right
443 that my
apology
hello
yes yes this is representative Mike
boards I'm the one that introduced this
bill um this was pushed on me by
actually a constituent of mine when I
was out door knocking um He was
discussing with me issues where military
personnel while in uniform have been
spat on
assaulted uh called all sorts of names
attacked and so on so just like we have
for police officers and First
Responders he um wanted me to push this
um by adding veterans and military
personnel to this
bill
thank you
representative representative pus you
recognized thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative for taking my
question would this mean for just in
uniform
only um that was my intent um I don't
think that's the
way um it was actually it wasn't
specific in the actual bill but that was
my intent yes thank you
seeing No Hands raised I want to thank
the representative for his
testimony thank
you the chair now recognize
representative
Edwards uh thank thank you Mr chairman
uh I'm representative Jess Edwards uh
representing Auburn Chester in Sandown
uh I'm a retired army lieutenant colonel
uh since 911 uh I deployed out of the U
Army National Guard and the Army
Reserves on on two separate
deployments and what I what I think when
I see this bill is um the the um
concerns I had when I was in Afghanistan
and we were reading in Intel reports
saying that there were domestic
terrorism plots that were targeting the
families of deployed soldiers back home
and the way I think my compatriots and I
thought about that was that um we we
knew what we were accepting we knew what
risks we were accepting and we were
there as a team trained equipped and all
of that but uh if our fortunately this
domestic terrorism
um didn't occur that I know of but I
would almost rather have this apply to
the member of a military Armed Forces uh
family more so because I the the threat
of domestic terrorism striking at a
soldier's family while they're deployed
is uh a much more harmful thing to U
society and our ability to U defend the
nation uh I I'm I'm not opposed to
having soldiers also protected by this
but my bigger concern would be
protecting families because uh that that
that can under undermine morale far more
than having one of your F fellow
soldiers um be U struck so that that's
my testimony if you have any questions
I'll i' take
questions
thank you representative for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised
representative
your at this time if there's any members
of the public who wish to testify that
have not testified already please raise
your hand uh the chair now recognizes
Kevin
Grady thank you Mr chairman uh ladies
and gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is Kevin Grady and uh I'm
a 22-year resident of hookit following a
25- year career uh in our air force
today I'm here representing the state
veterans advisory committee and for the
benefit of those members of the
committee who might be new or unfamiliar
with what we do we're chartered by state
RSA 110 to speak for the veteran
community in New Hampshire and we have
20 members as of last night when we
added the 20th member and these are
names that of organizations that are
probably familiar to you things like the
American Legion the Veterans of Foreign
Wars the military order of the Purple
Heart organizations like that one of the
things that we do is we we take a look
at all the bills coming before the
Senate uh and house and we pick out the
ones that we think have a better impact
and then we discuss those bills and we
come up with a position and then they
send me to testify to you and tell you
what it is that we think and so I'm here
to do that today but I'm also here to to
offer our services if you're intending
to write a bill that you think affects
veterans we're resource that you can use
to help make sure that that the bill
says what you want it to say and and
does what you want it to do our members
unanimously support this bill to be
honest most of them did not know that
there was in fact an increased penalty
in uh uh in 651 for these other folks
like uh firefighters and other First
Responders and and police officers and
we feel like perhaps belong in that
group as well um and I think it it's
even more uh need needed now if you take
a look at the visibility of our guard
members our guard members are out there
every single day Manning all the
vaccination sites in the state and uh
and doing the om's work and so uh we do
support this bill and and subject to
your question sir that's all I want to
say thank you for your
testimony the witness is
excused do any members of the public
wish to testify that have not testified
already please raise your
hand see no further hands raised this
time we close public hearing on House
Bill
443 the signs on House Bill 443 there
was one person who signed in supporting
the bill and five people who signed in
an
opposition thank you representative
I did receive a few questions
electronically just so the members of
the public know and the members
participating remotely both
representative Wallace and represent set
are physically in the room so the issue
of them turning the cameras on during
any votes um would not apply because
the to clarify
that this time we open the executive
session on House Bill 598 relative to
the portion of a minimum sentence be
served
Ser I like to make a
[Music]
motion
make a motion thank you Mr chairman I'll
make a motion of
it is that second repr Wallace
second you wish to speak on your
motion yes Mr chairman
um just hearing the
testimony it sounds
like you know there are exemptions that
you know especially the you know because
of the emails I got they talked a lot
about the
elderly um that there is you know about
their medical conditions um and there
was a gentleman that's I think he was
from the prison that spoke on that and
said um you know asked him the question
and he said that you can get a medical
exemption to have a parole here um you
know the kids they from Nation
um even though he was supporting the
bill he just gave a lot of information
you know it was almost like he was
against the bill because he was saying
how
wonderful the programs that he took and
how it reduced his sentence in so I just
look at this bill that it's not really
needed I think that um you know the
system is working and and I think we
should go with that thank you Mr
chairman representa GFF I did say I had
a motion but I think you didn't hear me
but um with that said I'm going to vote
against the itl and if you keep not just
my
well people refer to the medical issue
on 598 at no point the medical was
discussed on 598 the medical was
discussed on
138 so just letting you
know um what was important was the fact
that we're the only one at
100% And that's truly important the
other factor that came out in the middle
of 598 was the fact that if you wanted
to get earned credits you had to be able
to afford to pay for
it and if you were not able to pay it
you couldn't get earned
credits the other fact that came out
that you go if you for one of the other
um things that they had you go back
before the judge this says you go back
before the board that tells you and gets
information from the doc as what type of
person you've been in your term or what
you've done to you know rehabilitate
yourself that's entirely different from
138 so I definitely would vote against
this because I definitely feel that this
is a good bill if my um colleages had a
problem with the 50% where there many
states have 50% some states have done
away with truth and sentencing and um
the other fact that is last term when it
was suggested that we have a committee
it was Donna saitech that came and said
and voted against that even though the
doc had recommended it so my point of
the matter is is that you know either
you for or you're not whether you're in
a committee or you're not in a committee
but it's a definitely are doing the
bill representative thank you Mr chair
um I cannot I cannot support the bill
because I find the bill to be uh too far
too over far too broad this
reach well it doesn't make wouldn't make
any difference if a man if a person were
in prison for DW in which you hurt
nobody but
yourself or you in prison for
murder you get a 50%
reduction and
that's different crimes should be
treated in different ways and I can't
support those too broad thank
represent represent first okay
new thank you Mr chairman
um this hearing this bill was really uh
an educational experience I think every
time we hear one of these bills uh it's
an educational experience for all of us
I know as a first ter or the last time
um it was semi overwhelming try to take
trying to take in all of the uh the
information and the points that are made
I I and I I sympathize with those folks
who are here with us for the first time
while I'm sympathetic to the concerns
that are raised or that were raised by
the parole board and and while I'm uh
always extremely sympathetic to to the
families of victims I think the fact
remains that taking away a person's
Freedom um in this state is the worst
thing you can do to somebody and and
think when you do that uh the standard
uh not only to send people to prison uh
but to keep them there has to be very
high and when I look at the fact that so
many other states have moved off of this
law um other states uh are I think the
original federal law we heard testimony
was 85% for truth and sentence say New
Hampshire is the only state that's at
100% uh and most of the other states are
far far below that and I ask myself why
and I think a lot of a lot of it comes
back to the fact that we uh we do not uh
properly invest in the parole process
and in the parole board um they they
operate on shering resources and and I
think one way to look at that is that
saves us that definitely saves us some
money but one of the other things it
does is it creates resource constraints
uh that make it very very difficult for
people who know how much work they'd be
facing if we passed a bill like this to
go ahead and pass it and when I ask
myself what do I weigh more heavily is
it keeping a broken system limping along
uh is that is that the thing that's most
important to me or is it making sure
that somebody who deserves a chance of
Freedom or who maybe has earned a chance
um giving them just the right to have a
review
um and so I'll be voting against the itl
um my guess is is this issue uh is going
to be one of those issues that uh that
keeps coming back to us not only in
other bills this session but in bills
and other sessions and I I would just
urge everybody um I I wish I would have
prepared a little bit better for this
today because this is an issue that
really
deserves any and all attention that we
can put into it
this really does affect uh the lives of
the people who are in prison it affects
the lives of their families at home um
it affects us and our entire criminal
justice system so thank
you thank you represent representative
tman you recognize thank you uh I have
two points U I received a letter from a
prisoner on this uh opposing
but the letter and granted you know I
have no no background on him than what
was in his letter it wasn't very
sympathetic when you really shipped it
away
because he wasn't like the people who
testified were former prisoners you he
he clearly was not
accepting his part in in being
incarcerated he was merely complaining
about how bad the system was so you I
think we need to be very careful with
the people who testify
because there they are people who have
learned how how it works and you know
they present a good pH the other thing
is I heard today
about and these kind they said these
kinds of
laws Drive how many people we have in
prison and the impression you get is
that New Hampshire is is
imprisoning more people than we really
ought to more people probably than any
other state and so on and that's just
not true I looked up the statistics on
the incarceration by state out of 50
states we're in the bottom five of those
and and there's just there's a group of
them that are just sort of plus or minus
a few different but we don't incarcerate
that many people that tells me that the
I don't care really what other states
are doing but yeah I think maybe we're
doing the right thing about the balance
of who we keep and and who we let go so
I'll be voting against
this thank you representative represent
thank you Mr chairman couple things
stood out from that testimony earlier
today one was a comment that hard cases
make bad laws um that was in reference
as I understand to a very
awful uh homicide and a miscarriage of
Justice relative to the
sentencing that changed Newan uh
basically our our sentencing structure
for every other criminal that is then
sentenced in the
future another thing stood out is after
that
change uh sentencing itself did not
reflect new TR and sentencing so uh
which is what former speaker scitech
indicated so uh the result of that was a
tenfold increase in the number of people
serving prison sentences in our state
from around 200 to around 2,000 now it's
nice to know that it's declining
slowly but uh this bill makes a uniform
approach to addressing a prior
wrong um we heard about program in in
the system that determine when somebody
could be eligible for parole that system
can adjust to this new
standard um and lastly I'd say that um
this is not saying somebody will be
pared it will say they are eligible for
a hearing that's those are two very
different things these are ways to sort
of speed up somebody's
Rehabilitation it's a good bill and we
should pass
it
representative pakas yes thank you Mr
chairman in 2004 representative Welch
appointed me to do a study on the prison
system and we were at
264 people in
1984 in
2004 we were at 2
2600 and the truth and czen law needs to
be looked into and we need to change
it maybe this bill won't do it but
everybody better think about that I hear
everybody all these Cuts being made but
the prison is still going to people are
going to have to be dead in the clothes
and whatnot we need to look into
that thank
you represent represent Newman
thank you Mr chair I will be uh opposing
the itl on this bill I also think that
uh it's a good bill and serves its
purpose um I also thought I thought I
heard a comment that we ought to be
careful about people that testify and I
am completely um confused by that
statement if it was said thank
you
yes
represent thank you
CH after a lot of lot of thinking about
this bill I'm I'm going to support the I
but I think that what we should think
about doing in the near future is
adjusting the uh uh sentences that we
are now put have put in our uh system
and uh that would address some of the
issues of what what how many people we
are imprisoning and I so I'm willing to
do that at a later date thank
you g yes I just want to say again that
um even at half your sentences it
doesn't say that you're going to be
parole so if we believe that our parole
folks are honest upfront
and doing their job they're not going to
just let anyone go this is an
opportunity for a person that could
possibly be eligible because they've
done their programming they've done
whatever's necessary to
rehabilitate to have that opportunity to
go before the parole board but
again those on the parole board are the
ones that make the decision so I'm
asking my teammates to vote against the
itl
representative rhods thank you Mr
chairman I have a question that might be
um it might actually you might be able
to answer this but goes also along the
lines of what representative was saying
there appears to be a lot of a lot of
not in this particular Bill
and part where where it starts is a
question I have would this would this
apply for
future sentences or does this almost
look at everybody that is now in you
know in prison like how like how far
back would it go my interpretation of of
the bill as drafted is it would apply to
all sentences including people are
currently incarcerated as well as people
that are incarcerated the future that's
right and um it's 60 I'm sorry it's 60
days
AC
to become law but for everybody that's
in I'm sorry you're right so if
someone's in already in prison right now
serving a sentence and let's say they
serve 60% of their minimum sentence
already the minimum sentence five years
they would be eligible to two and a half
years even if they serve three years
that mean they would be eligible for the
meeting okay thank
you
so I just want to you know you guys use
the term eligible for parole which I
noticed that when I um had gone to them
I had put something different but they
did put eligible but for me I don't look
at it that way I think that it gives
them the opportunity to go before parole
board just that simple it's an
opportunity to go before the parole
board and I believe that the parole
board would make the right
decisions
[Music]
see seeing No Hands raised the matter we
put the
question the clerk Now call the role if
you are in support the motion of
legislate please say yay oppos please
say I ask that the representatives who
are not physically present in the room
to please turn on their camera to their
devices at
time Vice chairman Welch hi
representative B yes representative
Hopper yes representative green yes
representative Wallace yes
representative
testerman yes representative true y
representative CRA yes representative J
yes Clark votes yes representative har G
no representa office
no Representative o'n
no representative
B changeed my mind
muse
no representative Newman
no Representative
bden
no representative Conley
no representative Quin Knight
no representative Bradley
no chair votes yes Mr chairman the vote
is 11
y I vote of 11
y
most
pass will there be a majority report yes
Mr
chairman be a Minority Report yes yes
thank you this time we will close the
executive
session on House Bill
598 we are opening the public hearing on
House Bill 576 be VI victims
compensation
fund
represent signed up
introduce chairman I do not
see the crime
sponsor yes oh she is okay thank you Mr
chairman am here
representative Milla you are recognized
to
introduce thank you Mr chairman and
Ladies and Gentlemen of the CRI criminal
justice committee I'm Linda Mass Miller
I represent the towns of the Littleton
and
Bethlehem I'm here today to introduce
House Bill
576 which came before the criminal
justice committee last year as House
Bill
1263 where it was recommended ought to
pass by an 18-2 vote then went on to the
house calendar and finally moved to the
Senate where it was later tabled because
of
covid-19 excuse me hus Bill 576 would
amend the provision of the state's
victims compensation fund to allow
claims by victims of child human
trafficking or sexual abuse to be filed
at any time the nature of sex
trafficking is unique due to the common
trauma bonding that occurs between the
victim and the offender because of this
Bond it is common for survivors of
trafficking to not rec re uh recognize
their own victimization until they've
received comprehensive care and
services this realization could happen
any time after victimization and is also
compounded by the fact that in the sex
trafficking context many older Youth and
adult victims who were trafficked as
minors are still regularly identified as
prostitutes or cons consensual sex
workers not victims of a crime by
removing the filing deadline
acknowledgement is made that the
recognition of victimization and
obtaining enough stability to file for
compensation can happen many years after
exploitation ceases and that the victims
are still deserving and needing of
compens compensation if they choose to
address longlasting physical
psychological and emotional harm that
has been
endured this bill would also eliminate
the filing deadline for child victims of
sexual abuse or who were victims of
familial sex
trafficking House Bill 576 would also
remove the contributory fault
consideration for compensation relative
to child of children of trafficking or
sexual
abuse the committing of criminal
offenses is an inherent element of sex
traffic trafficking
victimization trafficking victims do not
engage in commercial sex or unlawful
practices by choice but are coerced by
either fraud deceit or
survival as such to suggest that human
trafficking survivors May contribute to
their own victimization would appear
unjust considering their circum
ances I know that last year concerns
arose about around the possibility that
excessive claims would be generated if
the two-year deadline was
removed um I checked with the Department
of Justice and in 2020 the Compensation
Program reported that a
425 applications for compensation that
were approved 33 were child sexual
assault claims and the were no claims
related to human trafficking in
conclusion New Hampshire's taken Giant
Steps in the area of human trafficking
by including child victims of sex
trafficking under the definition of of
abused and allowing the vacating of
nonviolent crimes committed by minors
being trafficked for sex HB 576 provides
these V victims of sexual abuse or
trafficking the right to
access some form of compensation long
after the egregious crime was
perpetrated against them thank you for
listening thank thank you representative
for your testimony thank
you and representative the chair May
inquire of a question you mentioned this
this is identical to a house bill from
the previous term do you mind repeating
what that house bill was hb1
1263 thank you representa thank you do
you know did is there a reason why
there's not a fiscal note attached to
this bill I
don't thank
you um I do know that there is someone
here from the victim's compensation fund
who can answer any questions you might
have that would have to do with the
monetary part possibly
thank you
representative yes Mr chairman I can uh
guess why there is no physical note
because the money is not going against
the general budget it's coming from a an
established
fund thank you thank
you see no further hands
raised the witnesses excuse thank you
again for your des and thank you are
there any members of the public who wish
to testify that are now that are in
attendance please raise their hands this
time the chair is
recognizing Ellen Cobb and uh the chair
discuss we going to limit testimony to
seconds thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Ellen Co and
I'm a resident of marac New Hampshire
and I'm very happy to come here today
and join representative mamila in asking
you to please support uh House Bill 576
I was one of many people last year part
of a very broad Coalition uh that
supported uh the equivalent Bill hp1
1263 um which uh those of you who are on
the committee may recall passed
overwhelmingly out of committee and was
uh passed on a Voice vote by the full
house before along with many other
measures it was derailed U by covid I'm
glad that it's back I'm glad
representative mamila is still um
leading on this and I ask you please uh
listen to her and pass this bill I think
it is good legislation and good policy
thank
you thank you for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised the
witness
isused CH recognizes
Jasmine
what's the
last f
i I'm not seeing the name yeah she
signed
up
J Marin
Marin Marina yep is that the
one oh that's
her hi can you hear me
yeah I'm my I'm A Survivor of commercial
sex trafficking I go by Jasmine Grace
Marino for my work but my married name
is fanaka sorry for the
[Music]
confusion ton is limited to 97 okay so
thank you for having me um Mr chairman
and Ladies and Gentlemen of the
committee um like I said my name is
Jasmine Grace I'm a survivor of the
commercial sex trade have been out of
sex trafficking and clean and sober for
13 years um I want to say that the
experience is very traumatizing and it
took over 10 years for me to tell anyone
what happened to me and I believe that
time should not be a factor to apply for
victims compensation because many
victims like me don't tell anyone
because sometimes we don't even know
that there is any help available or
because we're so ashamed we don't talk
about it I personally had no idea there
was victims compensation funding and
there is very limited funds available
and it's such a small amount that the
opponents will probably testify against
the bill on that presence so even a
small amount of financial help might
make the difference between getting some
counseling or clothing for a job so
we're able to restart our lives and move
forward so please
vote ought to pass on HB 576 and remove
time as a limitation from victim's
compensation funding thank
you thank you testimony seeing No Hands
raised the witness is
excused this time the chair recognizes
Maria
Perez i' asked her to unmute Mr oh there
she is Mr
chairman thank you m um I'm M
representative Maria Perez I represent
this 23 but today I speaking on behal
half of
myself um I'm probably going to take
more than two minutes because I and and
I respect if you told me that like stop
with my testimony in two minutes but I
just want to share my personal story um
I'm a victim of sexual
assault um I was raped by my my own
father but that's not not that that's
not the whole story so when I was 15
years old I met my ex-husband uh who was
47 years old when I met him I was only
15 years old but for me my story um to
survive started when I was 15 and I met
him he promised me to bring me to the US
and I he promised me to better life
after being Abus since I was five years
old um he um he was a US
citizen uh he um traveled back to the US
he sent me um with some people to travel
to the US when I was um going through um
guala in
Mexico I was abused I was sexual
assault by couple of people that I don't
even know who they
are and then the last time I was abused
by these people it was when I got to
California that was 33 years
ago I believe vict they should have the
right even though after 30 years or 10
years or whatever they should have the
the ability to ask for
help um it is hard for me to speak about
this and I'm proud to be a US citizen
I'm proud of like everything that I
accomplished I graduated from college
when I was 42 years old I went through
domestic violence I went through sexual
abuse but to be honest I'm proud of to
I'm proud to to be who I am right now
and proud who who the person that I come
but without the help all all these
organizations and without all the
support that I got I don't think I
wouldn't make it this
far and be able to help other victims
that's what I have the courage to be
talking to you and to be sharing my
story is not easy but I think sharing my
story is going to help other victim
and then it's going to help you to
understand that victims they need help
even after two years or 10
years thank
you thank you representative perz
testimon see seeing No Hands raised
representative your
EXC
desend the chairs
recognizing I'm not gonna
pretend Nicole is
unmuted good afternoon chairman and
members of the committee can you all
hear me just fine yes okay my name is
Nicole kiet and I am the administrator
of the victim Services Unit with the New
Hampshire Department of corrections I am
here in support of House Bill 576 I did
submit my written testimony
yesterday as an advocate working for the
victim Services Unit part of our job is
to assist victims by referring them to
or submitting applications for financial
assistance through the victim's
compensation Fund in fiscal year 2020
the victim Services Unit assisted seven
victims with victims compensation
applications and so far in fiscal year
2021 we have assisted eight victims with
applications of all of the applications
we have assisted thus far five
individuals are survivors of sexual
assault in beyond the two-year time
frame outline outlined in the current
statute although the number of
individuals that we assist with these
compensation claims seems small the
impact that the financial assistance can
have on an individual victim and his or
her family can be astronomical as it
removes some of the financial barriers
for victims as they take steps forward
in their unique healing process in cases
where Advocates are working with victims
to submit applications for victim's
compensation the reason for application
Mo most often centers around the
victim's desire and need to re-engage in
trauma inform therapy relocate for
safety purposes or for victim offender
dialogue expenses without the financial
assistance provided by the compensation
fund many of these victims may go years
without the support or therapy necessary
to continue to move forward towards full
healing or may continue to live in fear
due the due to the inability to relocate
within the past week I personally have
worked with a survivor of childhood
sexual assault who has been consistently
harassed by her perpetrator through
phone calls letters and by thirdparty
Family contact even though the offender
has remained incarcerated due to the
harassment and the reality of the
offender's eventual release into the
community the victim is seeking
financial assistance through the
Compensation Program to relocate to a
new area where the offender will be
unaware of her location and she can feel
safe and free from the harassment and
intimidation she has experienced but due
to her Current financial constraints and
the expenses related to re relocating
without the assistance of the victim's
compensation funding this victim may not
be able to re locate and will continue
to be harassed by the offender and his
extended family how we do have to limit
testimony to 9
seconds sure that's it thank you for
your time I'm open to any questions you
may have thank thank you again for your
testimony seeing No Hands
raised witness is excused
thank you this time that the chair
recognizes Bob Bob
dun Mr chair members of the committee
I'm Bob Dunn the director of public
policy for the Roman Catholic dasis of
Manchester and uh I'm here today to
register our support for House Bill
576 um I just said this to the committee
I'm sure a couple of weeks ago on House
Bill 180 but the Catholic Church
worldwide sees human trafficking as uh
to use the words of Pope Francis nothing
less than as he says one of the great
evils of our age um and I think uh in
looking at a bill like this it's
important to think about escaping from
Human Trafficking as something that
involves not just the first minutes of
that event but it also involves the
ensuing months and years as well
so bills like this obviously help
trafficking victims in that
indispensable effort of forging a new
post-trafficking life so I want to say
thank you to representative mamila for
bringing this forward um and thank this
committee for all of its work on this
issue this year and in Prior Years thank
you thank thank you Mr dun for your
testimony seeing No Hands raised
Witnesses excused if there's any members
of the public who wish to testify that
have not testified already please raise
your
hand see your hands
raised this time we will now close the
public hearing on House Bill
and Mr chair signin on this bill uh HB
576 there were 36 people signing in in
support of the bill uh zero people in
opposition and one person signed in
neutral thank you
repres address Public Safety Committee
would be in recess to
shared did you see
um representative calling yes sir
someone who works full time just like
you if you do have a word
matter vot on your bill
while but u i not that
any I was trying to accomplish the
timing
of
app Daryl and his wife for a walk I
assume that
was this
no representative Road yes you tell me
what the vot was
on3
certainly um I wasn't able to keep track
on here today well today yeah um
12 don't leave
me were just becoming friends
away represent
well you just don't want to end up on my
[Music]
laptop all right
boys
Sak
[Music]
home
yes we are in about one minute we open
the executive
session I don't have3 ready for I don't
how but I don't so give me one
afternoon at this time we are opening
the executive session House Bill
[Music]
443 thank you Mr chair Mr chair I move
uh House Bill 443 is expedient to
legislate and Mr chairman I'll second it
if you don't mind you can recogniz
second that motion you wish to speak on
your motion of inexp to legisl thank you
Mr chair
um this is again an overly broad
Bill uh that says uh that extends
uh protection to military
personnel however if if uh you were in a
bar somewhere and got into a fight with
a man or a woman and then found out
afterwards that they were in the
military this law applies to you and you
had no idea they were in the
military that is a major fault I find in
the
bill but the major fault I find in the
bill is because I do not favor making
blists
I do not favor making list that says
some people are more worthy of
protection under the law I believe we
should always go with equal protection
under the law and that's why I move itl
thank you Mr
chair was it
yes thank and I I appreciate the
comments and really I think it's
important even if the the actor knew the
person was a member the arm services
that person may not be active at the
time and it's that special class that
you refering to still be implicated even
when the person's on active duty and I
think I believe
that that that would be
problem
circum seeing seeing no further hand
raised the matter we put the
question the clerk will call the role if
you in favor of the motion of in being
to legislate please say yay if you
oppose please say nay I do ask the
members participating uh remotely to
please activate that camera devices
before the vote begins represent B it's
just a
request Vice chairman MCH
hi representative B yes representative
Hopper yes
representative green yes representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true P representative pre
yes representative du yes the clerk
votes yes representative Harry gathre
yes representative pakz
yes representative oarn
yes representative
yes representative Ms
yes repres Newman
yes representative Balden
yes representative Conley yes
representative hin Knight
yes representative Bradley yes chairman
chair votes yes Mr chairman the vot is
21 Z by vote of 21 days and zero names
the motion of being to legislate
pass majority report yes thank you
represent time now close the executive
session on House Bill
443 this time we are now going to open
the public hearing on House Bill 315
adding tresp as an acception to the
charge of criminal
threatening
196 excuse
me we all know the
word
right it's
3:15 excuse me House Bill
adding adding trespass to the exception
to the charge
of
thank thank
you of
committee committee
ever no
competition my name is Michael I'm from
Hook representing n District
24 and today I'm presenting HG
196 which talks about this uh defensive
use of
firearm I'm sorry defensive display of
firearms
uh it's uh we talked about the subject
before this one is also uh simple
clarification of our F
law where we're trying to prevent lives
uh from being lost we're trying to save
we're trying to deescalate things we
really would like to not resort to the
use of
firearms that's why we're
trying that's why defensive display of
firearm is a good thing it's a solid
thing I believe it should be
encouraged because I'd rather everybody
walked away peacefully from any
encounter they were facing their
lives rather to resort to something else
to violence so again this might change
are quite simple it's just a few lines
they don't talk about the use of
firearms this is about displaying a
firearm very similar to that you've
previously heard
here uh because
um yes and and this change needs to be
made in the chapter uh the DU with
criminal trespassing and criminal
threatening my bill makes an
exception to display a
firearm in cases when there is Criminal
Trespass going
on um so
again I I want to make sure the citizens
who display powerarm who trying to warn
of any potential trouble do not face
persecution persecution or any kind and
this is what my bill is about it's quite
simple nothing to do with the use it's
only just
thank you all take
questions thank you representative for
your
testimony representative G you recognize
for
question thank you and thank you for
taking my question um you say
display in in
um
display
definition is brandish if you are doing
it for the purpose you just
said um is
there yes would you
believe the have you
know I'm not an expert on English
language it's not my native tongue um so
the I have it
described display is something uh which
you show you make it visible you make it
known with an intent
brandish it contain intent to cause harm
somebody else I think it is not defined
at statute but displays a common
word represent representa calling
chairman thank you representative
I think what you're proposing is already
covered quite well in statute would it
be appropriate to read the current
statute and then ask you to explain how
your bill would
differ uh if I a question so yes the
question so I will read the statute and
then ask for clarity so the statute
currently reads
6314 section four person who responds to
a threat which would be considered by a
reasonable person as like to cause
bodily injury or death to the person or
to another by displaying a firearm or
other means of self-defense with the
intent to warn away the person making
the threat shall not have committed a
criminal act that's the current
statute so I guess I'm wondering how is
this different if this is the current
law that allows precisely what you're
proposing I understand you don't have
the law in front of you and I'm Sor to
you disadvantage but it sounds to me
like it's already covered in law uh
thank you for the question I believe
trespass Criminal Trespass is not
covered by the statute so this is what
we're trying to do to add it to the
statute about criminal
trespasses I I believe your question is
fair we don't debate the wayt this is we
we inquire understood wasn't quite
debate but that was that
was
represent you're
recognized Mr chairman um and thank you
representative um is there a specific
problem that this bill is trying to
solve well I heard uh thank you for the
question um I've had a good number of
folks coming to me looking at 2020 as
being somewhat of an unusual year with
riots
violence dozens of people dying a fire
bombing businesses destroyed homes
destroyed lives ruined the summer of
2020 so those folks are worried here in
New
Hampshire um they want to be able to
protect themselves they want to be able
to not be faced with violence
unnecessary
violence and this is what I'm doing here
uh even in New Hampshire last summer I
believe they were small business
businesses that were quite in fear of
being attacked when there were
demonstrations throughout the
cities so in in those cases we had uh
owners to owners basically stand in
front of the businesses trying to warn
all the attackers uh that works I
believe that's a great defensive uh
display of
firearms and this this
law uh makes the people who scared of
being attacked again uh not fear for the
attack as much because they know that
we're behind them 100% that we
encourage the defensive display of
firearm where there's a need and they
feel they do not feel threatened anymore
so I want to make it yeah so yeah that's
where I'm coming from thank
you representative t you recognized for
a
question
[Music]
muted represent P you have that mute
yourself
she unmuted
herself I
am
okay thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking my
question if the STS and other
places uh want to do this why would if
no one had damaged their place why would
this amount of $1,500 be in
here thank you for taking well thank you
for the
question $1,500 is actually part of the
uh trespassing chapter it's
U that's how three trespass is defined
in
63512 we're dealing with right uh that's
a different
yeah 63512 defines Criminal Trespass as
a
uh the minute or class B
felony uh speak subsequent
offense if the person recklessly causes
damage in the excess of
$1,500 um since this new chapter makes
it an exception um to the chapter about
Criminal Trespass we just using that
same dollar amount that the criminal
uses to delineate felony closby
felony thank
you representative Newman you
recognized thank you Mr chair and thank
you for representative for taking the
question I are you aware um are you
aware that the uh the way the bill is
worded at least in my opinion is that it
uh expands the ability to display a
weapon to all forms of Criminal Trespass
where the current law protects a certain
class of of criminal contact is that
correct thank you let
me
it
U you're able to display
firearm to someone who is scally
trespassing with a
threat um you will be able to with this
law so I'm sorry so the question I'm
sorry experiment
followup represent Newman you recognized
for a followup
question yes yes thank you Mr chair and
um do you agree that since it says the
entire the law of section four in its
entirety that that covers all of the
definitions of criminal trespassing in
that
law
uh I would yeah I would agree yes yes
Criminal Trespass yes that's what we're
trying to warn yeah thank
you repres representative Wallace you
recognize thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking my
question so this bill will provide legal
protection uh to a property owner who is
taking a defensive posture with a
firearm or another means of self-defense
to neutralize or deescalate to threat in
a criminal trespassing situation is that
my understanding is that correct uh yes
thank you that's perfectly
right representative G um
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um when I look at
6314 um that is for certain government
officials and you're
adding I'm
asking so are you adding um a new
paragraph under government
officials I think wrong
yeah
that's it says criminal threatening
amend RSA
6314 that's did I so he's adding four
because it only goes to
three go four mine's don't in this
book did I do something get something
different oh
here all right I went over
right
there he's adding to that
okay I apologize I was actually looking
at 6314
a
sorry okay
yeah thank
[Music]
you see your further hands raised I want
to than thank you representative for
your
testimony
CH recognizes Elliot
axelman discussion the chair we limit
testimony M the public to two
minutes chairman I don't see
him
sh recognizes Joe
handon good afternoon members of the
committee um nice to see you all again
my name is Joe Hannah I'm the vice
president for gun owners of New
Hampshire and I'm speaking in support of
HB
196 um I I think uh there was one I
forget who said it but there was
mentioned that this is a differ differ
between between brandishing and
displaying uh I I've just double checked
I went through the the search there's no
word brandishing in the rsas in New
Hampshire display is the only reference
to to showing uh anything whether it's
Firearms fireworks or whatever what may
have you
um there I think some of the confusion
is that uh we're not allowed to use
force in defense of premises or property
and there is uh already in the law a
section
6277 use of force in defense of premises
and a person in possession or control of
premises or a person who is licensed or
privileged to be thereon is Justified in
using non-deadly Force upon another when
and to the extent that he reason
believes it is necessary to prevent or
terminate the commission of a criminal
trespass by such other in or upon such
premises but he may use deadly force
under s such circumstances only depends
to the person is described under RSA
6274 or when he reason believes it is
necessary to prevent an attempt by the
trespasser to commit arson so you can
already use non-deadly Force so the
display is certainly non-deadly Force
course it doesn't authorize someone to
actually use that weapon but it can be
used as a warning so in conjunction with
the other statutes about using a firearm
to as a warning against serious bodily
injury or death um I think that's almost
a non-necessary part of the law because
if someone's going to seriously injure
you or kill you you have the right to
not only show them your fire armor
weapon but you have the right to to use
it in defense of yourself so this
actually makes everything much more
clear and uh using non-deadly force in
this
this uh Bill does coincide with Section
6277 use of force and defense of
premises so it is non- deadly force it's
just a display of
force thank
you thank you for your testimony oh
excuse me represent for you're
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
Canon for uh for coming to testify and
taking my question um so you you noticed
that brandishing is not defined in the
uh in our laws and neither this display
so are are we now are we going to say
that they are
equal uh we don't have to use either uh
we don't have to say they're equal the
word display is actually in our laws and
when there is no definition in the rsas
the courts will use the the standard
definitions found in a dictionary
thank
youcome see no further hands raised
witness is excused thank you all have a
good afternoon and if there's any
members of the public who wish to
testify uh attendance that haven't test
uh testified already please raise your
hands this
time the chair now recognizes Alan
Rice just a reminder your testimony will
be limited two
minutes
hello yes Mr rice we can hear you okay
thank you very much um Allan rice uh Gun
Owners of
America um Mr Hannon uh did a very good
job explaining um
the benefit to the bill um I just want
to add in the questions about
trespassing sometimes a trespass that
starts out innocently enough becomes
violent and the person owning the
property should not face criminal
prosecution for holding displaying any
firearm um it's common to carry a
handgun and a holster but a rifle would
be on a sling on a shoulder a shotgun
may just be cradled across the arms
and you know defensive display as we
talked about in a prior Bill a few weeks
ago is a very valid uh self-defense
concept um so I just want to put Gun
Owners of America on record in support
of the bill keep it under two minutes
and I'm happy to entertain any
questions thank you Mr rice for your
testimony representative Hopper you're
recognized for a question uh thank you
Mr chair uh what is your your take on uh
the part of the bill that says likely to
cause property damage in excess of
$1,500 how's that going to play out in
court well
$1,500 um thank you for your question
representative Hopper
$1,500 is the threshold in New Hampshire
when vandalism of private property
becomes a
felony
[Music]
seeing no further hands raised I want to
thank the witness for his
testimony recognizes Maria
Perez thank you Mr chair um this is the
state representative Maria Perez and I'm
testifying against this
bill uh we don't need any more bills
that is going to give people a right to
um even though that people sometimes
like me and myself sometimes just walk
around the neighborhood and this this
kind of build doesn't make me feel safe
because sometime people just uh
discriminate just because they don't
like the way you look they don't like
the way you talk or they they just
barely or they just don't like you and
this is given people the chance
to give them the right to uh show their
guns and then try to threatening you
with the guns and the other thing
is myself myself I I I have people
trespassing my house many times my
property one of the occasions someone
trespassing my property and asked for my
husband and this person had the
intention of arguing with my husband and
getting into a fight with my husband and
I say no and this person pushed me on my
own
driveway but personally I didn't respond
to that
because um if you know yes I'm a US
citizen but I'm an immigrant and the L
uh threaten us differently because even
we US citizens we don't have the same
protection in someone who who was born
in here so I believe this law uh I will
I will not support this 196 because it's
not not given any protections for people
from the minority groups when it comes
to like uh try to protect them and
showing the gun when someone showing in
the
properties thank you representative for
your testimony seeing no hand seeing No
Hands raised representative you're
excused
and then just the record please say your
full name to the
record where you where you're from and
whether you be testifying in support or
opposition to House Bill
196 Mr chairman um that person there
their hand was not up I did ask on mute
I'm not sure if they wanted to speak I
think by accident they got down below by
a technical problem if I may said oh so
I do apologize for my technical
problem no problem at this time the
chair recognize
JR this was a reminder your testimony is
limited to two minutes thank you Mr
chair this is JR hole for the record can
you hear
me yes we can hear just fine thank you I
I am testifying on behalf of myself as
well as the New Hampshire Firearms
Coalition um I serve on the board of
directors as um the corporate secretary
we are in support of the bill as filed
um and we agree with the testimony of
both Gun Owners of America as well as
gun owners of New
Hampshire and I think at a high level no
one should be penalized for um simply
displaying a firearm that should not be
considered a crime and criminal
threatening is already well defined in
RSA 63 one in terms of Acts and behavior
and just merely holding a firearm or in
the case of uh Mr rice pointed out right
carrying a shotgun around potentially
with both hands if you're walking on
your property shouldn't be considered a
crime by itself the crime is the
threatening part and that's already well
defined in statute so I would ask that
you would support the bill as is if
there's questions I will gladly take
them thank
you
[Music]
see no hands raised the witness is
excused thank
you there's any members of the public
who wish to testify that haven't
testified already please raise your
hand seeing No Hands raised at this time
we will close the public here in House
Bill
Mr chairman on House Bill
196 we had 12 people sign in in support
of the bill and we had 53 sign in in
opposition thank you representative m
EXC me did I make a comment what we just
had that section that was amended by the
last bill appears in two places in the
rsas same exact wording and I put the
bill in and I didn't know it was in two
places well which which RS you referring
well it appears in 6:30
[Music]
for
four and criminal threatening also
appears in
44 physical force in defense of a person
same exact
words just a curiosity I guess I didn't
realize I had amended it
twice
I wasn't here to say
that just pass it anyway make sure it's
safe
also can I make note of two people that
are or two organizations that oppos the
bill would that be
okay we're not any no formal hearing so
okay New Hampshire legal assistance and
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual
Violence and a slew of other people but
I thought it was worth noting some of
the groups that we're consistently
hearing
from I ask questions see we're not doing
anything
specifically May so so company comes on
to my property I live out in out in way
out in the woods somebody coming on my
property pretty deliberate it's not like
wandering off the street on my prop and
I walk out of my house with a shotgun
because I have no idea what the hell
they're doing I also don't know that
they're going to actually do any damage
if this log goes through am I now guilty
of brandishing a
firearm I mean in where I think I can
bury the evidence pretty successfully
but let's just understand the term
brandishing is
display yeah use the terms differ
brandishing is Define in the federal
okay anyway I'm displaying my firearms
I'm proud of
it and trying to encourage them to leave
the
property is if this pass like right now
what would happen versus if this passes
what will happen in my opinion and this
is just my opinion I I don't feel that
this the mere Act of displaying a
firearm in the state of New Hampshire is
a crime under any circumstance under the
federal definition what makes it
brandishing is that when you when you
display the firearm with the specific
intent to to intimidate or threaten
someone so that's what makes brandishing
it requires displaying but it requires
an additional Acts or intent to do
something
so if you were simply just walking down
the street open caring in New Hampshire
which is been the law as long as I can
remember that is only considered
display now I would I would also say
that if you were to take your firearm
and pointed at any individual or even
unless is for a lawful reason to defend
yourself I don't feel you can simply say
I am just displaying a firearm when I
when it's that fire being pointed at
person no I would never do that unless
they they were actually threatening me
I'm talking somebody's on my property I
don't know what they're doing I walk out
of the house with my shotgun am I
guilty I don't know what I they might be
doing $100 damage you property Potion No
long as you don't point it at him you're
not
guilty I think I understand what you're
saying dollar amount be a concern the
dollar amounts just screwed me up well
we can do represent is I know there's
two executive sessions that we can get
moving
on but I think this is something that we
um maybe have a further conversation on
the committee in in the executive
session I want some homework
[Music]
on I don't want to tell people they
won't be guilty of a crime
then no I just want to use you as a
defense if I get caught
can't you'll probably need
at this time we we going to we opening
the executive session on House Bill 205
relative to incarceration under a
suspended
sentence the chair recognize
representative
true thank you Mr chair Mr chair I move
House Bill 205 to be to retain and Mr
chairman if I may second that m been
seconded
by representative true representative
B
true represent you wish to speak to your
motion to thank you Mr chair
um I remain uh
confused and
bolded on the 18 months uh serving
before two3 of the minimum sentence if
you're in for six years
18 months before two3 of six years
probably is not going to give you enough
time to complete any programs that you
may or may not
need
um I have questions on the bill that
perhaps they might get answered if you
retain the Bill thank you Mr
chair m recogniz
yes just a reminder that this was a bill
that we passed um 20 to nothing uh in
the previous session uh and the only
thing that has really changed
substantially in the bill uh is
something that caused the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections uh to endorse
it uh we also have endorsements of the
bill from the
ACLU uh and the uh New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
I mean this is a pretty good bill and I
know sometimes uh when you look at these
things the first time they can be a
little confusing but I think part of our
job is to sort of sort through some of
the confusion uh not just
to defer confusion until September or
October when we can get around with it I
we're not doing you know based on some
of our other votes you know we we
haven't done uh a great deal for people
who are uh who are incarcerated I think
everybody acknowled knowes that there
you know we have issues uh in our in our
prison system with um allowing too many
people um uh to be incarcerated beyond
the time they probably should be um this
is a bill that would help us address it
in a in a very measured way it's not
extreme uh it's not a get out of jail
free card um uh all it essentially does
is move up the time that somebody
would be eligible uh uh to
um essentially to complete uh things
that are required of them uh before
their sentence could be suspended and
you know I I'm having a hard time
understanding what we need to change
about it the the bill was actually
changed that's what the amendment was
about um in response to some of the
concerns we had even last year so I'm
sort of at a loss as to why the itl but
or the retain but it is what it
is although there's no Amendment offer
representative news do you mind just
explaining that am were
offered I'm sorry Mr chair I couldn't
quite make your
make was an amendment it's not offer but
it just 205 can't offer to an
itl offer
I'm aware you are I'm aware that's why
they
makeer I think the issue is that the
folks in the prison system felt that the
original 18 months that was in the bill
um wouldn't give enough time for people
who just qualify uh under the under the
bill uh to be to be eligible for it it
wouldn't actually give them enough time
to complete programs but when you reduce
that to to 12 months it means that
they're actually serving more time so
that there's time uh to complete those
additional programs so a lot of times
when we look at 18 months to 12 months
it seems like oh you know we're being
more we're being more lenient um in in
this partic particular case we're making
it a little bit more difficult uh for
people to do this who are eligible you
know who might be eligible for this uh
sooner so you know you know to me this
seemed to be a a pretty good uh
compromise to get this bill
through see no further hands raised the
rep put the
question in favor the motion please say
yes you oppos please say
next I would ask the members that are
participating remotely please activate
the cameras at this
time chairman Welch
hi representative B yes representative
Hopper yep representative green yes
representative Wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true y representative
Pratt representative uset yes the clerk
votes yes representative Harry GFF no
representative panus
no representative o hear
no representative B
no representative muse
no
no representative Balden no
representative Conley no representative
P Knight no no representative Bradley no
chairman chair V
yes 11
10 by vot 11 Y and 10 the motion
forain allow or it's passed this time we
will close the executive session
on
205 this time we will now open the
executive session on
576 that's relative to victim
compensation eligability time theair
recogniz
representative represent wel make a
mo we retain House Bill
[Music]
second
think what we need to do is to determine
is squ
this
fund comes from where the where the
money rate whether not tax funds some
other
funds and uh
I think we need to do that before it go
to the floor
so if we rain it we'll have a chance to
uh check that
out representative Muse you
recognized I I thought I heard in
testimony that uh that there's no fiscal
note on this bill because the money is
coming from an established fund
uh versus from the general fund or did I
hear that
wrong right I asked I asked the question
of the
Witness believe representative bour Pro
provided an answer that question
and that's my Rec
recollection yes chairman that is as it
is the way what happened and uh
I uh can't see any reason that we would
want to retain this
bill well that fund gets depleted at
some point and the money has to come
from somewhere to fill it up again corre
we just need to determine where that
money comes
from representative n you
recognize thank you um it comes from the
Attorney General's office it's online
victims Compensation Program grants and
management in the state of New
Hampshire
thank represent P you
recognized thank you Mr chair it's my
understanding they run out of money they
run out of money nobody gets paid this
is just a special fund for
that thank
you you're right I want to say that was
my understanding too last year when we
had all those different bills and it the
money comes out of that fund when when
it's gone it's gone at no point did
anyone talk about going from the
taxpayer or any of those types of
things
so I think that we should be moving on
with the bill uh there's no reason
really to retain
it I will I will just let the members
know we are meeting uh scheduled to meet
next Wednesday and if it is retained and
if anyone wants bring forward some
information to present to the chair and
vice chair of the committee or the
committee as a whole as you can tell
from today and other other days we've
done reconsiderations the past but I
think at this point the matter we put
question the cler call the role you in
favor motion please say yay if you oppos
please say
name Vice chairman Welch hi
representative B yes representative hoer
yes representative hi representative
Wallace yes representative testerman yes
representative true yes representative
Pratt yes representative
yes yes representative Harry G no
representative pus no Representative
oarn no representative
bour uh yes oh
no representative muse
no representative Newman
no Representative bden no representative
Conley
no representative K Knight no
representative Bradley no
chairman chair votes
yes vote is 11 y
10 11 Y and 10 n the
mosted remain pleas don't speak
us this time we'll now close the
executive
session
on House Bill
576 who second
that just just a reminder next Wednesday
we are scheduled to meet we are also on
it's going to be no in the calendar that
scheduled for further executive sessions
on
Thursday that will only be obvious if
it's necessary for us to meet if the
idea we
can we can get
done some changes in the deadlines but
for now that's what how it's scheduled
so we try to make good use of our time
next
Wednesday
har is W next Wednesday the one you
wanted to stay very
late
yeah yes could you appoint some find a
replacement for me then
I will notify the speaker's office requ
substitute
followup so see that I won't be here if
we take this previous Bill back up could
somebody amend it so we finance that
that fund by selling the organs of
the traffic and human traffic we can
sell
or my God oh my
that really wasn't
necessary that
not public safy
committee did I not hear him
correct I want to know if we're meeting
next
Monday
next Wednesday we are meeting not not
Monday we probably if we're late we will
not have Thursday correct if we finish
[Music]
everything to be here
THS
spe
guess the meeting's
done don't know they don't tell us much
well I think it was adjourned it's hard
to tell but I think we're adjourned
Laura did I hear him
right uh we I believe you did and it's
probably not for discussion right
now
okay Airman is still there and we're
still
recording so when not meeting on Monday
at
all no Wednesday not unless they change
it and it's in the calendar that might
happen but this is still being recorded
as I understand so and apparently I
don't know whether they they can't hear
us in the room apparently but I'm gonna
sign out
now me
too bye everyone Bye by